comme vous savez chers collègues nous
poursuivons aujourd'hui l'examen pour
avis des missions budgétaires relevant
de la commission des lois avec l'examen
de la mission juste ici qui comporte
deux avis en préambule je vous propose
de procéder à la nomination du
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle visant à garantir le
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et j'ai reçu la candidature de
Madame Aurore berger que j'ai nomme donc
rapporteur de ce texte qui sera examiné
par notre commission le 9 novembre
prochain
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre de la Justice monsieur garde
des sceaux ou nous présenter aujourd'hui
votre budget un budget qui pourrait à
troisième année consécutive augmente de
8% alors bien évidemment un bon budget
n'est pas forcément un budget qui
augmente mais c'est mieux lorsqu'il
augmente et donc c'est mon rôle que de
le souligner il s'agit d'un rattrapage
puisque comme vous l'avez dit le
la situation du ministère avait été
dégradée de nombreuses années et se
rattrapage et loin d'être anecdotique il
n'est pas non plus achevé il sera durant
ensuite par un examen d'une proposition
d'un projet de loi pardon que vous nous
présenterez au début de l'année
prochaine via les états généraux de la
justice vous allez nous présenter ce
budget en présence de nos rapporteurs
puisque nous avons deux rapporteurs pour
avis madame saratanzili pour la justice
et l'accès aux droits puis monsieur
Pouillard
Eric Pouillat pour l'administration
pénitentiaire et la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse avec également
notre rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances Monsieur Patrick
ketzel qui a demandé à pouvoir
intervenir
ce que nous allons donc faire c'est
d'entendre d'abord votre audition
monsieur le ministre l'intervention de
la première rapporteur les différents
intervenants pour la première mission
puis le alors les deux rapporteurs
pardon effectivement puis les orateurs
des groupes les trois rapporteurs
puisque je vous avais oublié monsieur le
rapporteur spécial les orateurs des
groupes et ensuite une série de
questions pour lesquelles je prendrai
vos inscriptions respectives monsieur le
garde des sceaux vous avez la parole
pour votre propos introductif
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur spécial madame
monsieur mais rapporteurs pour avis
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la justice je crois à la croisée des
chemins elle a été
délaissée pendant près de
trois décennies
il a fait l'objet depuis 5 ans d'un
renforcement massif traduction de la
volonté claire du président de la
République et la première ministre mais
également
traduction de ma volonté de considérer
la justice pour ce qu'elle est une
institution essentielle qui fonde le
pacte social
il vous revient en tant que
parlementaire de poursuivre
sur cette voie du renforcement de notre
justice ou
de bifurquer vers les réflexes des
décennies passées
sous dotation chronique et d'affichage
sans lendemain
court termisme etc etc etc et vous
l'aurez compris je vous propose en ce
qui me concerne de rester sur la voie
engagée de la restauration massive d'une
justice rapide efficace plus proche de
nos concitoyen la justice de qualité que
tous nous appelons de nos vœux
en effet après deux hausses de 8% en
et 2022 le projet de budget que j'ai
l'honneur de venir vous présenter
aujourd'hui
devrait permettre d'autoriser une
troisième hausse consécutive de plus de
8% en 2023 au profit de notre justice
ce sont ainsi 710 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui viendrait abonder en
2023 service public de la justice
qui c'est le vrai est un 9,6 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2023
si vous la votez cette hausse de 710
millions d'euros pour l'année 2023 sera
en termes sonnant et trébuchant la plus
grande hausse de l'histoire du budget de
la justice
comparé respectivement à des hausses de
600 60 millions d'euros l'année dernière
620 millions d'euros l'année précédente
cette
ours pour massive qu'elle soit était
calibrée pour que les services du
ministère soit en capacité de l'exécuter
pleinement en réponse à des besoins
forts qu'il nous faut combler de manière
sérieuse et efficace car oui les deniers
publics doivent toujours être utilisés
de la manière la plus efficace
c'est moyen important il permettront
d'augmenter
d'alimenter les trois grands axes de ma
politique
et réseau d'acteurs du ministère
plus 9% pour les services judiciaires
pour atteindre
3,39 milliards d'euros pour 2023
+ 7 % de hausse de crédit consacrée à
l'administration pénitentiaire souhaite
un budget de
3,91 milliards d'euros pour 2023 sans
oublier monsieur le rapporteur pouya une
hausse de plus de 10% au bénéfice de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
atteignant atteignant donc ainsi 917
millions d'euros pour 2023
en trois budgets ce sont deux milliards
d'euros de crédits supplémentaires
passant ainsi de 7,6 milliards d'euros
en 2020 à 9,6 milliards d'euros 2023
qui sont venus
bénéficiaires à la justice
ceci représente une hausse de plus de
26% du budget de la justice en trois ans
depuis mon arrivée et plus de 40% si
l'on prend comme point de départ
le début du premier quinquennat du
président de la République
c'est donc un nouvel effort budgétaire
inédit
s'inscrivant dans une trajectoire
pluriannuelle inédite que j'aurais
l'occasion de vous présenter
prochainement dans le cadre de la future
loi de programmation pour la justice
2023-2027
le cap est parfaitement clair
ce budget va nous permettre de
poursuivre le rattrapage de 30 ans
d'abandon humain politique
financier de la justice et de mettre en
oeuvre les recommandations
issues des États généraux
recommandations que j'ai soumise à
concertation
ces derniers mois
permettez-moi maintenant de vous
présenter dans le détail ce que ces
moyens supplémentaires permettront de
financer en 203 et sur les années à
venir
premièrement mesdames et messieurs les
députés la justice est avant tout une
question de femmes et d'hommes engagés
au quotidien au service de nos
concitoyens pour faire fonctionner
contre vents et marées le service public
de la justice et je veux ici à cet
instant rendre un hommage appuyé à leur
engagement sans faille merci au
magistrats au greffier au personnels
pénitentiaires au juriste assistant aux
avocats aux professions du droit
administratif pour leur engagement dans
l'œuvre de justice
vous le savez pendant trois décennies
ces hommages ont eu lieu chaque année
sans que les actes ne soient joints à la
parole
depuis 2017 nous nous sommes précisément
donné les moyens de remplacer les mots
par des actions concrètes de
reconnaissance et de renforcement de
notre justice
je suis aujourd'hui devant votre
commission pour confirmer que nous
allons accélérer dès 2023 et sur les
cinq prochaines années le rythme et
l'intensité de ces efforts pour le
renforcement humain du service public de
la justice c'est pourquoi comme vous
l'avez indiqué le mois dernier ce budget
acte le plan de recrutement le plus
important de l'histoire du ministère
de 10 000 emplois supplémentaires
pérennes les sucres lents si je puis
dire qui sera mis en place d'ici 2027
dont 605 emplois en juridiction qui ont
d'ores et déjà été pérennisé au titre de
la justice de proximité à la mi 2022
c'est inédit et pour faciliter les
comparaisons
même si comparaison ne vaut pas raison
je voudrais rappeler par rapport au
quinquennat précédent ce sont
7270 emplois qui ont été créés sur le
premier quinquennat du président de la
République
puis par rapport aux effectifs existants
du ministère nous sommes aujourd'hui
environ 90 000 personnels travaillant au
service du ministère de la Justice ce
qui représentera donc une hausse de 11%
des emplois qui sera atteinte d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
c'est 10000 emplois seront répartis
finement année après année
en fonction des besoins qui nous
remonteront du terrain mais également
des besoins opérationnels résultantes à
la fois des campagnes de recrutement qui
seront mises en place
et de l'avancement des projets
immobiliers très ambitieux portés par le
ministère
néanmoins parmi ces 10 000 emplois
supplémentaires je peux d'ores et déjà
vous annoncer que seront sensuels
sanctualisés la création de 1500 postes
de magistrats
1500 postes de greffiers supplémentaires
sur tout le quinquennat afin de
renforcer les effectifs en juridiction
pour comparaison
les créations de postes et de magistrats
greffiers ce sont élevés respectivement
à hauteur de 700 700 magistrats 850
greffiers sur le premier quinquennat
nous doublerons donc le rythme de ces
recrutements essentiels
maintenant concernant 2023 ce sont
2253 personnels qui arriveront dans les
établissements pénitentiaires dans les
juridictions et dans les structures de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
en comparaison avec 2022 720 créations
d'emplois étaient prévues en 2022 nous
triplons donc en 2023 le rythme des
recrutements en une seule année c'est
2253 personnels seront répartis de la
façon suivante
1220 pour la justice judiciaire avec
notamment 200 magistrats et 191
greffiers
809 pour l'administration pénitentiaire
92 pour la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse le reste soit 132 personnels
bénéficiera à la coordination de la
politique publique de la justice par
ailleurs
60 créations d'emplois sont prévues pour
nos opérateurs 26 pour l'École nationale
de la magistrature 19 pour l'agence
publique pour l'immobilier de la justice
15 pour l'agence de gestion et de
recouvrement des avoir saisis et
confisqués
deuxièmement mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour assurer ce niveau inédit de
recrutement je souhaite renforcer encore
l'attractivité des métiers de la justice
par des revalorisations salariales à cet
égard le budget 2023 permettra une fois
encore de hausser les crédits obtenus au
titre des mesures catégorielles
atteignant ainsi les 80 millions d'euros
pour 2023 afin de revaloriser les
personnels les professionnels pardon de
ce ministère à titre comparatif cela
représente un doublement de l'enveloppe
déjà conséquente de 2022 et une
multiplication par plus de 5 depuis 2019
concernant les magistrats comme je l'ai
annoncé dernièrement une revalorisation
inédite sera mise en place à compter du
1er octobre 2023 à hauteur de 1000 euros
brut par mois en moyenne
il en Vala de la juste reconnaissance de
l'engagement qui est le leur pour faire
fonctionner le service public de la
justice dans des conditions parfois
difficiles et je veux dire ici et à cet
instant que je suis particulièrement
conscient des difficultés matérielles
qui demeure et c'est bien pour cela
d'ailleurs que je m'échine décrocher les
budgets les plus conséquents
depuis
trois ans que je suis au ministère et
j'accepte volontiers qu'il soit comparé
budget qui était ceux du ministère de la
Justice dans des temps plus éloignés
je
me bats parce que
j'ai la certitude bien sûr que nous
avons fait beaucoup mais qu'il reste
beaucoup à faire
et contrairement à ce que certains ont
pu retenir je n'ai jamais dit que la
justice était réparée
j'ai dit que j'avais réparé l'urgence et
puis
[Musique]
et puis un journal n'a pas retenu
l'intégralité de mon propos je pense que
ça nous arrive à tous
et
il convient de redire les choses nous
avons réparé l'urgence mais j'ai
toujours affirmé qu'il restait beaucoup
de choses à faire et d'ailleurs si je
n'avais pas cette certitude chevillée au
corps je ne me serais pas battu
notamment pour mettre en place les États
généraux qui nous permettent de
simplifier les procédures bien
évidemment et de renforcer les moyens
dont notre justice a tellement besoin
pour tous ceux qui font des leçons
[Musique]
qui nous font des leçons longueur de
journée
tous ceux de tout bord
qui n'ont pas été capable de ramener un
seul centime pour les magistrats pas un
centime pour les greffiers pas un
centime pour les agents pénitentiaires
pas un centime pour les sucres rapides
d'ailleurs c'est nous qui les avons
inventés les sons de morale je dis d'une
certaine façon ça suffit je vais vous
dire franchement oui il reste beaucoup à
faire mais il n'est pas encore élu le
gouvernement qui aura fait mieux que
nous en la matière
surtout quand on sait que en deux ans
pour les moyens de la justice nous avons
fait plus que la gauche en 5 ans vous
voyez et pour la droite on ne peut même
pas calculer tant les chiffres sont
négatifs je vous ai donné le chiffre de
magistrats que nous avions recruté sous
Monsieur Hollande bah c'est pas vrai
mais c'est pas vrai bien sûr que si
c'est vrai et puis on va pas commencer
comme ça monsieur bernalicis on va se
parler dans le respect chacun son tour
vous aurez la parole nous nous avons
embauché nous nous avons embauché plus
de 700 magistrats sous Monsieur Hollande
sous Monsieur Hollande 27 ce monsieur
Sarkozy c'est un chiffre négatif puisque
on taillait à l'âge dans la fonction
publique et on ne remplacé pas les
magistrats qui peuvent être à la
retraite alors moi je le dis avec force
concernant les fonctionnaires 2023 sera
une grande année avec une enveloppe
catégorielle de 50 millions
j'amplifierai ainsi l'effort consacré
depuis trois ans
deux objectifs de la politique que je
poursuis l'attractivité bien sûr de tous
les métiers de justice et la
fidélisation des femmes et des hommes
qui travaillent au service de la justice
de notre pays concernant les greffiers
en particulier les forts inédits
consacrées à la revalorisation
indemnitaire des greffiers et des
directeurs de services de greffe sera
poursuivi et plus de 10 millions
consacrer à cette fin en 2023 et au
total c'est une augmentation de 12% dont
bénéficieront les personnels de greffe
entre 2021 et 2023
par ailleurs j'ai demandé au directeur
des services judiciaires d'engager une
réflexion sur une réforme du statut des
greffier
concernant les personnels relevant des
corps spécifiques de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse 7 millions
seront consacrés cette année encore à
des revalorisations indemnitaires cette
nouvelle étape vise bien sûr à
poursuivre la convergence avec
les rémunérations de corps équivalents
et ce n'est là que justice
enfin concernant les surveillants
pénitentiaires nous finalisons en 2023
la mesure de revalorisation de
l'indemnité pour charge pénitentiaire
qui est passé de 1400 euros à
1869 euros sur trois ans les
surveillants pénitentiaires ont
bénéficié en 2022 d'une réforme
importante de leur statut et de leur
rémunération la fusion des grades de
surveillants et de brigadier a permis de
simplifier la carrière des agents de
revaloriser de façon importante le
salaire indiciaire notamment en début et
en fin de carrière comme je l'ai
toujours dit cette réforme était la
première étape des travaux seront
engagés dès le début de l'année 2023
avec les organisations syndicales pour
travailler à une revalorisation
d'envergure de leur statut et de leur
rémunération qui sera mise en œuvre dans
les années suivantes
je peux m'arrêter un instant pour dire
au personnel pénitentiaire
que nous devons à tout moment le rendre
hommage ils font un travail absolument
extraordinaire c'est un travail qui est
un travail difficile c'est la troisième
force de sécurité dans ce pays on a
souhaité notamment qu'il ne soit plus
que
qu'il ne soit plus porteur de clés mais
qu'il soit
agent pleinement
intervenants c'est la charte du
surveillant acteur que j'ai signé avec
eux et il y avait une vingtaine d'années
qu'il n'avait pas que tous les syndicats
n'avaient pas accepté de signer une
charte avec le garde des choses sur ces
questions voilà je veux chaque fois que
je parle d'eux souligné à quel point ils
sont absolument indispensables et à quel
point ils appartiennent à la barque
républicaine et judiciaire laquelle nous
sommes tous très attachés
on doit vous le savez ouvrir des
établissements pénitentiaires
établissement pénitentiaire du plan
15000 pour donner tous les moyens pour
recruter plus et dans les meilleures
conditions et pour fidéliser les agents
qui exercent des missions nécessaires
difficiles je viens d'en parler nous
avons tous ceux-là l'esprit je souhaite
dire également
que nous devons porter au corps
d'encadrement une attention particulière
qui soit directeur de service de greffe
directeur d'insertion de probation
directeur de service de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse ou directeur
des services pénitentiaires tous ces
agents surtout quotidien eu une mission
délicate dans des conditions difficiles
et portent des politiques complexes en
faveur des personnes que nous prenons en
charge pour toutes ces raisons près de
10 millions d'euros seront consacrés
cette année à une revalorisation de leur
régime indemnitaire mais également à une
revalorisation de leur régime indiciaire
troisièmement mesdames et messieurs les
députés ces crédit permettront de
poursuivre et de finaliser le plan de
construction des 15000 places de prison
supplémentaires voulu par le Président
de la République j'y suis pleinement
engagé et ce sont environ la moitié des
établissements qui seront opérationnels
en 2024 sur la cinquantaine de chantiers
en cours de plus à l'heure où je vous
parle ce sont 18 opérations qui sont en
chantier dans toute la France
par exemple une nouvelle construction
des Baumettes
740 places réhabilitation de l'ex-centre
de jeunes détenus de Fleury-Mérogis qui
permettra la création de 408 nouvelles
places en 2023 pas moins de 10
établissements pénitentiaires seront
livrés cette structures d'accompagnement
vers la sortie dont Avignon Valence mot
hosnie et trois centres pénitentiaires
donc quand trois Lavaux que j'ai pu
visiter en juillet dernier en 2023 ce
sont plus de 441 millions qui seront
budgétés pour la réalisation du
programme 15000
s'agissant des livraisons la mise en
oeuvre du programme a été marquée à ses
débuts par la difficulté des recherches
foncières
souvent pour des raisons de faisabilité
technique ou environnementales
pense à la découverte d'espèces animales
protégées notamment
mais également mais également
d'acceptabilité de la part des élus ou
des riverains
un peu comme les mccains c'est ceux qui
en parlent le plus qui en mangent le
moins
voilà en matière de sécurité donc ceux
qui réclament le plus ceux qui montent
au créneau ceux qui en ont fait leur
thématique préférée cela ne sont pas au
rendez-vous des obligations citoyennes
et du courage qu'il faut à un élu pour
dire au ministère de la Justice oui on
accepte dans notre commune dans notre
circo la construction d'un établissement
pénitentiaire j'ai ouvert cette
parenthèse je la referme immédiatement
voilà
on va dire aussi que ces recherches ont
été entravées par des démarches
contentieuses voilà mais les terrains
nécessaires au lancement de l'ensemble
des projets mais tout ça c'est
aujourd'hui
identifié les opérations ont pu entrer
dans une phase active et le rythme de
livraison va maintenant s'accélérer pour
s'échelonner jusqu'à la fin 2027 et nous
serons au rendez-vous des
engagements du Président de la
République
je tiens également à souligner que ce
plan 15000 compte près de 2000 places de
SAS
afin d'offrir un meilleur accompagnement
ou détenus pour lutter avec acharnement
contre la récidive on parle le temps des
récidives
oui et c'est un échec et à chaque fois
il convient sans doute de s'y rater mais
on ne parle jamais du détenu qui ne
récidive pas et pourtant et pourtant
quand les sorties ne sont pas des
sorties sèches selon la formule
consacrée nous avons expertisé chez nous
par tout en Europe d'ailleurs qu'il y a
moins de récidive et donc c'est une
direction qu'il nous faut suivre le plan
de 15000 portera plus de 75 000 places
de prison
nous laisse d'ailleurs entrevoir très
sérieusement pour la première fois
la teinte de notre objectif de 80%
dans cellulement individuel à l'horizon
nous nous proposerons donc de projet
pour la dernière fois le moratoire en la
matière pour que sa fin coïncide avec la
sortie de terre de la totalité du plan
enfin
je souhaite également engager les
opérations de réhabilitation nécessaire
des établissements pénitentiaires les
plus vétustes parfois scandaleusement
vétuste et en particulier l'opération
majeure est prioritaire de
réhabilitation du centre pénitentiaire
de Fresnes dont Monsieur le Président
Houllier vous savez qu'elle est
nécessaire puisque vous l'avez visité
dernièrement avec les députés de cette
commission afin d'y montrer sans doute
que non la prison n'est pas selon une
expression reprise parlant d'entre vous
le Club Med il faut dire d'ailleurs que
tous les parcs d'attractions
ont les noms des parcs d'attractions ont
été utilisés pour qualifier la prison
à l'hôtel 4 étoiles le Club Med Astérix
quatrièmement
mesdames et messieurs
les députés je
souhaite
agrandir l'immobilier juridictionnelle
pour permettre l'accueil des renforts
humains dans les années à venir petit
retour en arrière petit flashback d'un
instant pour dire deux choses bien sûr
on a construction des établissements
pénitentiaires il y a la question de la
dignité de la détention
mais il y a aussi les meilleures
conditions de travail pour le personnel
pénitentiaire quand les conditions
dignes il y a plus de sécurité pour le
personnel pénitentiaire je pense qu'il
est indispensable de le dire de le
rappeler et bien sûr de le marteler et
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre et dans la
conception je me fais de la prison il y
a bien sûr assuré une réponse pénale
ferme mais sans démagogie et de
l'humanisme mais sans angélisme parce
que les conditions de détention dignes
permettent aux personnels pénitentiaires
de mieux réinsérer
et nous évoquons chaque fois que nous
construisons un nouvel établissement
pénitentiaire la place pour accueillir
du travail en prison
car
vous le savez notamment nous avons
conditionné
les remises de peine à l'effort nous
avons supprimé les remises de peine
automatique et il faut que nous
envisagions dans la construction des
établissements pénitentiaires de quoi
stocker du matériel notamment pour les
entrepreneurs
je viens maintenant à la modernisation
d'immobilier juridictionnelle permettant
l'accueil des renforts humains dans les
années à venir alors au total mesdames
et messieurs les députés se sont
502 millions d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement et 269 millions d'euros en
crédit de paiement immobilier qui sont
prévus en 203 pour permettre
de poursuivre les opérations d'ampleur
engagées lors du quinquennat précédent
et notamment de poursuivre les chantiers
tels que le palais de justice de Lille
l'île de la Cité à Paris Bayonne et
naturellement d'autres chantiers de
poursuivre les études des projets de
Cayenne
QC mot moulin Nancy Nantes - Perpignan
là encore d'autres projets sont à
l'étude et je pense que ces projets au
cœur de vos circonscriptions voulaient
vous les connaissez et enfin pour
permettre de lancer de nouvelles
opérations immobilières je pense à
Argentan Chartres Colmar Saint-Brieuc ou
Verdun enfin
cinquièmement et dernièrement mesdames
et messieurs les députés je souhaite
mettre en lumière certains budgets qui
permettront de moderniser et d'améliorer
concrètement le fonctionnement du
service public de la justice ainsi que
le bien-être des agents
de crédit consacrée aux dépenses de
frais de justice sera portée à 660
millions d'Euros pour renforcer les
moyens d'enquête et d'expertise de la
justice soit une hausse de 12 millions
d'euros supplémentaires ceci porte un
160 millions l'effort consenti sur ses
moyens depuis mon arrivée cet effort
contribuera notamment à faciliter le
déstockage des affaires qui est d'ores
et déjà d'ores et déjà mis en place et
je vous donnerai les chiffres que nous
avons puisque en matière civile je vais
même vous les donner maintenant il y a
un déstockage des affaires civiles sur
le plan national qui est de plus de 30%.
ce déstockage est évidemment du temps
judiciaire de gagner et c'est du temps
que nos compatriotes n'ont pas à
attendre
quand il sollicite l'intervention de la
justice
puis les crédits d'investissement
informatique seront portés à 195
millions d'euros dans le cadre de la
poursuite de la mise en œuvre du plan de
transformation numérique ministérielle
ces crédits concernent principalement la
mise en œuvre des grands projets
informatiques comme
Astrea attiji 360 Portalis ou encore la
PPN procédure pénale numérique en
parallèle la mise à niveau technique des
infrastructures telles que les centres
de production et le réseau sera renforcé
j'ai dernièrement recruté un secrétaire
général adjoint en charge du numérique
et des informaticiens seront déployés
massivement dans toutes les juridictions
pour répondre immédiatement aux besoins
du quotidien et notamment en matière de
de panne en matière de bug un
informaticien par juridiction pour
intervenir tout de suite enfin les
crédits de l'accès au droit et la
médiation vont s'élever à
713 millions d'euros en 2023 ce qui
représente une hausse de 33 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2022 5% de plus
plus spécifiquement dans cette enveloppe
les crédits dédiés à l'aide
juridictionnelle continueront de croître
en 2023 pour atteindre
641 millions d'euros ce qui est équivaut
à une hausse de 26 millions d'euros en
une année environ plus
4%. parallèlement
l'aide aux victimes est porté à 43
millions d'euros souhaite une hausse de
7%, ce qui traduit bien sûr l'importance
que je porte à cette politique qui
constitue vous le savez une priorité
gouvernementale et au sein de cette
enveloppe
madame la rapporteur tanzilis 16,1
millions d'euros seront dédiés aux
violences intra-familiales marquant un
doublement du budget vif qui était de 8
millions d'euros à mon arrivée en 2020
enfin sur l'action sociale offerte par
le ministère des agents sont
renforcement sera poursuivi avec 38
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés en
2023 soit 8% de plus qu'en 2022 35
millions d'euros pour rappel voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés les
grandes lignes du projet de budget 2023
pour la justice qui frôle désormais les
10 milliards d'euros que j'ai l'honneur
de vous présenter cet après-midi je
répondrai naturellement et avec grand
plaisir à toutes vos questions
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole
était même la rapporteur Sarah tanzini
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis avec poulya Monsieur le Rapporteur
spécial Patrick Etel mes chers collègues
le budget qui vous est présenté
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans une dynamique
de renforcement des moyens de la justice
totalement inédites dans la 5ème
république dont nous pouvons être fiers
il constitue un signal majeur envoyé à
notre administration judiciaire pour
renforcer l'attractivité des corps de
magistrats et de greffiers ce budget
prévoit une revalorisation importante
des rémunérations pour améliorer le
fonctionnement de notre justice et
soulager les personnels ce budget
prévoit la création de 1220 postes en
2023 dont 200 magistrats et 191
greffiers
pour anticiper l'arrivée de promotion
plus importante permettant d'atteindre
l'objectif de 1500 magistrats et 1500
greffiers supplémentaires d'ici la fin
du quinquennat nous renforçons les
moyens de l'École nationale de la
magistrature et de l'École nationale des
greffes
s'agissant des quatre programmes liés à
la justice judiciaire et à l'accès aux
droits ces engagements forts se
traduisent par l'augmentation de 7,2%
des crédits de paiement traduction
budgétaire des revalorisations et des
recrutements mais aussi de
l'augmentation des crédits pour les
associations d'aide aux victimes et des
structures d'accès aux droits
cette année la thématique de cet avis
budgétaire porte sur l'accès au droit et
l'accompagnement des personnes victimes
de violence intrafamiliales
une des clés pour garantir que les
victimes puissent exercer leurs droits
et de multiplier les lieux et les
dispositifs où elles seront en contact
avec un professionnel susceptible de les
accueillir et de les orienter les
commissariats et les gendarmeries ont
ainsi mis en place des procédures pour
que la victime de violence conjugales
puissent se signaler sans avoir à
verbaliser la raison de sa venue le
travail des associations d'aide aux
victimes et de ce point de vue
fondamental et je me réjouis donc que le
budget de ces associations augmente de
plus de 11% cette année des outils ont
également été élaborés pour aider les
professionnels en contact avec de
potentiels victimes à évaluer
correctement la situation le ministère
de l'Intérieur a par exemple diffusé une
grille d'évaluation du danger qui
comporte une vingtaine de questions
j'ai pu le constater au cours de mes
auditions depuis le Grenelle des
violences conjugales en 2019 la lutte
contre les violences conjugales a changé
d'échelle des progrès réels ont été
accomplis sur l'accueil des victimes
grâce à ses outils aux formations mises
en place à la meilleure coordination des
acteurs assurés via les copils vif
pilotées par les juridiques les
juridictions et surtout grâce aux moyens
déployer puisque l'enveloppe budgétaire
a loué aux victimes de violence entre
affamiliales à doubler entre 2020 et
2023 comme vous l'indiquez monsieur le
ministre passons de 8 à plus de 16
millions d'euros des progrès peuvent
encore être faits notamment en formant
encore plus largement les professionnels
qui sont en contact avec les victimes je
pense notamment aux professionnels de
l'enfance en particulier les enseignants
et les Atsems qui sont en première ligne
pour identifier et libérer la parole des
enfants victimes de violences dans le
cercle familiale
au droit passe également par la
connaissance des dispositifs de
protection dédiés aux personnes victimes
de violence intrafamiliales et en
premier lieu les ordonnances de
protection c'est une première réponse
judiciaire qui n'est pas conditionnée au
dépôt d'une plainte le nombre de
demandes d'ordonnance de protection a
augmenté de
73,4% entre 2018 et 2021 pour s'établir
en 2021 à 5921 démontrant démontrant la
montée en puissance de ce dispositif le
nombre de téléphones graves danger
déployés a lui aussi exploser en
quelques années plus 700% entre 2017 et
2022 l'objectif de 5000 téléphones
déployés sur tout le territoire devrait
pouvoir être atteint d'ici la fin de
l'année
de l'accès au droit et de
l'accompagnement des victimes de
violence intrafamiliales en particulier
des victimes mineures je tiens à
souligner le caractère fondamental du
travail accompli par les administrateurs
haddocks qui ont vocation à représenter
un mineur dans une procédure judiciaire
lorsque les représentants légaux de ce
mineur ne sont pas en capacité de le
faire ou que leurs intérêts divergent de
ceux du mineur or le nombre
d'administrateurs haddocks a tendance à
stagner voire diminuer dans notre pays
alors que les conditions d'indemnisation
des administrateurs Haddock n'ont pas
été revalorisées depuis 2007 la
protection des victimes de violence
intrafamiliales doit aussi progresser
sur le volet de la prise en charge des
conjoints violents des premiers centres
ont été ouverts après le Grenelle des
violences conjugales ils sont maintenant
30 sur la totalité du territoire en
parallèle l'expérimentation sur le
contrôle judiciaire avec placement
probatoire lancé en 2020 qui permet
l'éloignement du conjoint violent et sa
prise en charge en pressentiel se voit
prolonger d'une année
nous serons certainement amenés à nous
pencher sur l'articulation et la
pérennisation de ces dispositifs ou si
je me permets d'insister sur la
nécessité pour les victimes de continuer
à créer des lieux d'accueil pour les
conjoints violents car il s'agit d'une
condition indispensable au maintien à
domicile de la victime et de ses enfants
lorsque celle-ci soit de rester au
domicile conjugal
monsieur le ministre après cette brève
présentation de mes travaux j'ai
quelques questions à vous poser
concernant l'attractivité de la filière
de greffier devenue une nécessité comme
la teste le taux de vacances des
greffiers de 7%
vous nous avez annoncé que un travail
est en cours pour réformer la filière
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus
l'idée de la création d'une catégorie A
des greffiers qui permettraient de
renforcer l'attractivité de la carrière
est-elle envisagée et quels seraient les
impacts budgétaires d'une telle
évolution
envisagez-vous de réévaluer les
conditions d'exercice des
administrateurs adoptent qui jouent un
rôle fondamental dans la défense des
intérêts de l'enfant victime
l'idée d'intégrer les frais de
signification au défendeurs de la
décision d'acceptation de l'ordonnance
de protection dans les frais de justice
a été émise à plusieurs reprises au
cours de mes auditions ce qui serait de
nature à renforcer l'effectivité de la
décision de justice est-ce envisageable
plusieurs interlocuteurs m'ont fait
remonter des difficultés avec les
bracelets anti-rapprochement qui
condiraient à des alarmes intempestives
le ministère mène-t-il des actions
correctrices
pouvez-vous également me confirmer que
le groupement d'intérêts publics
nouvellement créé France protégée se
chargera bientôt de lancer une campagne
de sensibilisation sur les violences
sexuelles commises sur les mineurs c'est
un sujet qui me paraît prioritaire au vu
du nombre de victimes mineurs chaque
année victime de violences sexuelles
estimée à 160 000 par la civisme
je vous remercie
merci madame le rapporteur Éric
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur pour avis
s'arrête en Dini monsieur le rapporteur
spécial Patrick ketzel chers collègues
je voudrais tout d'abord assister sur
les ordres de grandeur de ces deux
budgets dédiés à l'administration
pénitentiaire et à la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse commençons par
cette dernière son budget global
représente 1087 millions d'euros en
crédit de paiement en augmentation de
17%, soit 103 millions par rapport à
l'année précédente au sein de ce budget
les dépenses de personnel augmentent de
13,6% et les crédits hors ma salarial de
6%
s'agissant de l'administration
pénitentiaire maintenant son budget
global s'élève à 4 milliards 900
millions d'euros en crédit de paiement
en augmentation de 7 et demi pour cent
soit 343 millions d'euros par rapport à
l'année 2022 au sein de ce budget les
dépenses de personnel augmentent de 8,6
%, il est crédits hors ma salarial de
5,7%
rappelons également que ces deux budgets
ont été en constante augmentation au
cours des projets de loi de finances de
la précédente législature ce nouveau
projet s'inscrit donc dans la continuité
de cette dynamique de progrès que l'on
doit avant tout saluer car elle montre à
quel point notre majorité et le
gouvernement ont pris la pleine mesure
des enjeux cruciaux que porte la
politique pénitentiaire et celle de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
avant d'en venir à la partie thématique
de mon rapport je voulais souligner un
enjeu budgétaire qui me semble tout
particulièrement important et qu'on
laisse pourtant souvent de côté
en 2017 nous avons été confrontés à un
véritable problème quant au mauvais
niveau d'entretien des établissements
pénitentiaires parce que les budgets à
louer et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre avait été sous-évalué pendant
des années voir des décennies en effet
selon une étude conduite par la
direction et l'administration
pénitentiaire le budget nécessaire à la
maintenance du parc pénitentiaire est
estimé à 140 millions d'euros par an or
entre 2014 et 2016 60 à 80 millions
d'euros seulement ils ont été consacrés
et les résultats étaient désastreux
notamment parce que la vétusté de
certains bâtiments menaçaient la dignité
des conditions de détention
je me réduis je me réjouis de voir que
nous avons redressé la barre
c'est budgets ont été en constante
augmentation depuis 2017
80,7 millions dans le projet de loi de
finance pour 2018 100,6 millions pour
2019 110 millions pour 2020 110 millions
pour 2021 120 millions en 2022 et cette
année encore le budget continue dans
cette direction avec 124,6 millions
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement et
en crédit de paiement pour la
maintenance et l'entretien des
établissements
cajons que les prochaines années nous
permettront d'atteindre le niveau adapté
selon l'évaluation réalisée par
l'administration pénitentiaire
j'en viens à présent à la seconde partie
de mon rapport que j'ai choisi cette
année de consacrer aux activités de
réinsertion au milieu fermé comme en
milieu ouvert je tiens à préciser que
j'avais choisi ce sujet avant l'été car
je souhaitais notamment travailler sur
l'émission des services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et probation après autrement
SPIP
mais la polémique de cet été n'a fait
que provoquer ne fait que prouver pardon
la pertinence de ce choix car nous
devons visiblement faire encore preuve
de pédagogie pour expliquer l'importance
de la politique de réinsertion et des
activités proposées aux personnes
placées sous-mains de justice d'ailleurs
le budget demandé pour 2023 ne s'y
trompe pas puisque les crédits dédiés à
cette politique sont eux aussi en
augmentation notamment pour le
déploiement du bracelet
anti-rapprochement dans le budget
augmente de près de 145%. le
développement du placement extérieur
dans le budget augmente de
67,5%. la mise en oeuvre des réformes
liées au travail en détention et aux
nouveaux statut de détenus travailleurs
avec un budget en hausse de 28%. je me
réjouis de ces augmentations qui
montrent combien la politique de
réinsertion est aujourd'hui une des
facettes essentielle de la politique
pénitentiaire
en milieu ouvert nous devons continuer
de développer toutes ces formes de suivi
qui permettent de s'adapter au profil
des personnes condamnées et ainsi de
construire avec eux un parcours de
réinsertion le plus adapté possible en
milieu fermé les activités proposées aux
personnes détenues recouvrent plusieurs
domaines travaillent formation
professionnelle insertion par l'activité
économique enseignement activités
éducatives culturelles socioculturelle
sportive et physique toutes ces
activités organisées au sein de la
détention participent du quotidien
carcéral et des parcours de réinsertion
des personnes détenues on comprend bien
la porte des activités de formation
d'enseignement ou de travail évidemment
mais les autres ont également leur rôle
à jouer en effet les apports
socioculturels permettent aux personnes
détenues de développer notamment leurs
compétences sociales et leurs capacité
relationnelles qui sont un maillon
essentiel de la réinsertion
en conclusion il me semble important de
rappeler que la politique de réinsertion
est mise en oeuvre notamment par les
services pénitentiaires d'insertion et
de probation les spips qui sont souvent
bien moins identifiés par nos
concitoyens que les personnels de
surveillance ils exercent pourtant des
missions essentielles assurant la fois
le contrôle des obligations prononcées
par l'autorité judiciaire notamment au
milieu ouvert et l'accompagnement
personnalisé des personnes placées sous
l'injustice ils sont ainsi au premier
rang de la lutte contre la récidive
alors monsieur le ministre au cours de
mes auditions et de mes déplacements
j'ai été alerté à plusieurs reprises par
le manque d'attractivité des services
pénitentiaires d'insertion et de
probation les directrices et les
directeurs de ces services ont
d'ailleurs récemment lancé un mouvement
social pour rappeler pour réclamer une
amélioration de leur statut je les ai
reçus et j'ai pu échanger avec eux sur
ce sujet pouvez-vous nous indiquer
comment le gouvernement prend en compte
ses enjeux et quels sont les mesures
catégoriales qui sont mises en oeuvre ou
qui le seront à l'avenir en faveur de
ces personnels dédiés à la réinsertion
et envisagez-vous de continuer le
recrutement des CPIP conseillés sur le
reste du quinquennat
je m'interroge également sur la mise en
oeuvre en janvier prochain de la
nouvelle procédure de libération sous
contrainte de plein droit le projet de
loi de finance pour 2023 prévoit ce
titre le fléchage de 30 agents de
surveillance électroniques plusieurs
syndicats ont indiqué que ce nombre
risqué d'être insuffisant pour prendre
en charge les nouvelles mesures de
détention à domicile se surveillance
électronique qui seront mises en oeuvre
dans ce cadre pouvez-vous m'indiquer
comment seront gérer les mesures
prononcées en application de cette
nouvelle LSC je vous remercie merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur de la spéciale sachant
qu'après votre intervention je
suspendrais pour que vous puissiez aller
voter en séance
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs pour avis mes chers
collègues ce budget pour 2023 semble
traduire les premières conséquences que
le ministère entendirait des
recommandations formulées par le Comité
des états généraux de la justice c'est
une bonne chose toutefois derrière des
effets d'annonce je tenterai de vous
démontrer que la réalité était lasse
bien plus complexe et ambigu qui n'y
paraît s'agissant de la justice
judiciaire il convient en premier lieu
de rappeler que les difficultés
structurelles des juridictions sont
considérables à titre d'exemple le taux
de vacances des postes de greffiers
s'établit à 7,2 % soit 2,7 points de
plus qu'en 2019 c'est-à-dire avant la
crise du covid de plus les cibles fixées
en matière de délai de traitement des
affaires civiles repartent à nouveau à
la hausse la première ministre a annoncé
lors de son discours de politique
générale la création de 1500 postes de
magistrats sur 5 ans 200 et TP
supplémentaires de magistrats sont
prévus par le projet de loi de finances
pour 2023 sans doute que les 1300 postes
alimentaire seront pour plus tard
néanmoins le ministère reste dans
l'ambiguïté ces emplois relèvent-ils de
création de poste au sein des
juridictions ou d'ouverture de place
supplémentaires à l'École nationale de
la magistrature en d'autres termes ces
renforts seront-ils opérationnels en
2023 ou à compter 2025 seulement de plus
monsieur le ministre vous avez annoncé
une revalorisation à hauteur de 1000
euros de la rémunération des magistrats
à partir d'octobre 2023 cette dernière
prendra la forme d'une hausse des primes
forfaitaires et modulables versées au
magistrat en réalité nous voyons bien
que cette revalorisation concernera en
priorité les magistrats les plus
expérimentés dès lors que ces primes
sont indexées sur le traitement
indiciaire et surtout cette prime ne
résoudra pas la question centrale de
l'attractivité de la profession
s'agissant de l'administration
pénitentiaire en dépit de la livraison
de nouvelles places de prison la
population carcérale continue de
progresser bien plus vite le taux
d'occupation des places en maison
d'arrêt pourrait atteindre plus de 130%
en 2023
toutes ces conditions comment espérer
une véritable amélioration des
conditions de détention
le projet de loi de finances prévoit par
ailleurs la création de 809 emplois
encore une fois il convient de souligner
la réalité de la situation ces postes
concernent majoritairement des
personnels de surveillance pour
lesquelles nous l'avons vu au cours des
derniers budgets le schéma d'emploi est
hélas systématiquement sous-exécuté il y
a des annonces et ça ne suit pas
derrière des moyens supplémentaires
seront en outre alloués au bracelet anti
rapprochement néanmoins comme la
d'ailleurs indiqué y compris notre
collègue Aurélien Pradier de nombreux
dysfonctionnements ont été répertoriés
sur ces outils ce qui a conduit le
ministère a changé de prestataire en
2022 cet exemple montre qu'en dépit de
moyens supplémentaires le pilotage fait
toujours défaut en fait sur l'article 44
du projet de loi de finances il nous est
proposé de prolonger de deux ans
l'expérimentation rendant obligatoire
une tentative de médiation préalable à
la saisine du juge pour certaines
affaires familiales sur le principe j'y
suis favorable toutefois je dois
signaler que ce la troisième fois que
nous prolongerions cette expérimentation
et que selon les informations dont nous
disposons la CNAF n'a toujours pas donné
son accord pour participer à son
financement nous nous prenons donc sur
un article sans savoir quelle en sera la
véritable portée enfin monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi de citer des
acteurs du terrain judiciaire récemment
dans ma circonscription lors de
l'audition de rentrée la présidente
d'une part et la procureur du tribunal
judiciaire de Saverne d'autre part ont
dressé un état des lieux je voudrais les
citer ainsi madame la Présidente dit
nous sommes en situation de plein emploi
théorique l'équilibre demeure fragile et
du côté des greffes la situation est
plus que délicate nous sommes en
sous-effectif chronique avec des postes
non pourvu nous obligeant à prioriser
certains services et à ne traiter que
les urgences pour d'autres
je cite à cela madame la procureur
ajoute là aussi je me permets de la
citer le mérite de tous ces grands car
la justice est le seul service public à
devoir absorber chaque année dans les
faits et à moyen constant ces salariés
une quantité énorme de réforme et ce
dans tous les domaines vous le voyez sur
le terrain les choses sont un petit peu
différentes que dans vos discours pour
conclure tous ces exemples montrent que
100 pilotage satisfaisant de ses moyens
supplémentaires la justice ne pourra
sortir durablement de la crise qu'elle
traverse encore aujourd'hui beaucoup
restent donc à faire et jusqu'à présent
les résultats ne sont hélas patients
monsieur le ministre vous l'aurez
compris la justice de terrain lorsqu'on
l'interroge celle du quotidien celle qui
la vie effectivement dans les tribunaux
et là aussi elle est très éloignée de ce
que vous venez de nous présenter et donc
ma question est très simple monsieur le
ministre à quel moment accepterez-vous
d'en venir enfin au principe de réalité
je vous remercie
dès lors qu'on a deux orateurs encore en
séance je vous propose de donner la
parole à même Caroline Abadie pour le
goût Renaissance
aujourd'hui le budget justice qui dans
la continuité des cinq années
précédentes et marquées par une hausse
historique de 8% le portant ainsi à plus
de 9 milliards 600 millions d'euros
depuis 2017 nous avons considérablement
renforcer les moyens humains et
techniques de la justice après une
augmentation budgétaire de 40% sur la
période de 2017-2022 le budget que vous
nous présentez monsieur le ministre
conserve la même dynamique au nom du
groupe Renaissance je salue votre
travail pour l'effort budgétaire réalisé
votre engagement témoigne votre volonté
de pérenniser et d'améliorer les actions
entreprises pour moderniser le service
public de la justice au service des
Français
ce budget pour 2023 promet d'ailleurs
une trajectoire ambitieuse pour la
prochaine loi de programmation qui
interviendra dans la continuité des
états généraux de la justice en
engageant des projets structurants pour
votre ministère
en effet après la création de plus de
7000 emplois lors du premier quinquennat
10000 créations de poste ont annoncé
pour la période 2023 2027 dont 2253 ETP
des 2023 au service de nouveaux
établissements pénitentiaires au service
de la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse et bien sûr au service de nos
juridictions augmenter leur nombre
augmenter leur rémunération pour
valoriser à sa juste valeur leur mission
et attirer les meilleurs
208 postes de magistrats 191 greffiers
sont créés sur ce projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 l'objectif d'ailleurs
d'en créer 1500 pour chacun de ses
postes sur le quinquennat aussi ma
première question tourne autour du phase
de ce déploiement formation recrutement
et déploiement sur nos tribunaux j'en
veux pour exemple tribunal de Vienne
cette année qui était complet en terme
de magistrats mais qui était en dessous
en termes de greffier
des efforts similaires renforcent et
modernise l'accès aux droits en effet
salut la progression de 26 millions
d'euros de crédit budgétaire alloué à
l'aide juridictionnelle
voler essentiel de la politique d'accès
aux droits dans le même temps plus 7% de
crédit accordé à l'aide aux victimes
axée sur une prise en charge
pluridisciplinaire et plus
spécifiquement pour les victimes de
violence conjugales ces moyens
permettent de financer des outils
majeurs de la protection des victimes
comme par exemple les 5000 téléphones
graves dangers
s'agissant de l'administration
pénitentiaire monsieur le ministre je me
réjouis de voir ses moyens renforcés
avec un effort tout particulier consacré
à la réinsertion
renforcement des moyens humains des
conseillers de probation et d'insertion
financement pour accompagner le
déploiement du contrôle judiciaire sous
placement probatoire pour les auteurs de
violences conjugales renforcement des
moyens de la tige
l'Agence nationale du tige et de
l'insertion professionnelle autant de
moyens mobilisés à l'indispensable
mission de réinsertion des personnes
placées sous-main de justice
concernant plus précisément la formation
professionnelle monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais savoir
et j'aimerais que nous précisiez les
objectifs et le mode de co-financement
que vous avez pu envisager avec les
régions
concernant la convention que vous avez
signé avec elle en début d'année pour
rappel depuis le transfert de cette
compétence de la formation
professionnelle aux régions nous sommes
passés de 40% de détenus formés à moins
de 12%
avec la poursuite du plan 15000 places
nous avons donc ici deux leviers
complémentaires qui permettront je
l'espère de réduire la surpopulation
carcérale particulièrement en maison
d'arrêt ce qui m'amène à vous interroger
monsieur le ministre sur les
réalisations qui sortiront de terre en
2023 vous nous avez dit 10
établissements j'aurais aimé savoir
combien de places supplémentaires net
cela pouvait recouvrir
enfin je tiens particulièrement à saluer
l'engagement de l'ensemble de personnels
de la PJ du pénitentiaire confronté
quant à eux à des conditions de travail
toujours très difficiles contenu de
l'occupation carcérale grandissante et
je voulais donc réaffirmer ici que ce
budget nous permettait de dire que la
prison punit surveille mais également
réinsère merci madame la députée donc je
vais suspendre pour que vous puissiez
aller voter pour le vote solennel
la parole est-elle orateur du groupe
rassemblement national Monsieur Thomas
ménager pour une durée de 4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le pragmatisme
nous invite tout d'abord à saluer la
hausse des crédits alloués à la justice
par ce budget 2023 néanmoins le réalisme
nous oblige à nous rendre à l'évidence
en décelant sous séos un véritable
budget de l'impuissance non ce budget ne
permettra pas de rompre avec le laxisme
judiciaire face à l'insécurité qui
gangrène l'ensemble de notre pays depuis
des années monsieur le ministre vos
fonctions font de vous d'abord le garant
de l'exécution des peines prononcées
pourtant tout est fait pour ne plus les
exécuter je n'invente rien ce sont vos
chiffres qui le démontrent seul 21% des
personnes condamnées à une peine
inférieure ou égale à 6 mois font
réellement l'objet d'une détention pire
vous souhaitez aller vers 18% en 2023
16% en 2024 puis 14% 2025 au lieu de
poursuit en bonne et due forme après la
commission d'un délit les alternatives
aux poursuites ou les peines
alternatives dont vous êtes friand et
Tonton c'est pourtant qu'elles n'ont
aucun effet sont en constante
augmentation
le taux de rappel à la loi par délégué
du procureur de la République passera de
30% en 2020 un objectif de 47% en 2025
le taux de Pen aux alternatives allant
ferme passe quant à lui de 76,9% en 2020
un objectif de 81 % en 2025 c'est sur
cette base et ses prévisions que se font
donc ce budget de la justice un laxisme
inacceptable pour les victimes et
contre-productives pour prévenir la
récidive je ne peux que vous citer ces
mots de Beccaria que vous devez sans
doute connaître la certitude d'une
punition mais modérée fera toujours plus
d'impression que la crainte d'une peine
terrible si à cette crainte se mêle
l'espoir de l'impunité vous devriez vous
en inspirer et c'est tout le sens de nos
propositions et du projet de Marine Le
Pen pendant les présidentielles qui
proposait de privilégier les peines
courtes réputées plus efficaces pour
prévenir la récidive et éviter que la
petite délinquance du quotidien ne se
transforme en grande banditisme l'État
par votre intermédiaire abandonne
progressivement une de ses missions
régaliennes en la sacrifiant sur le
thème de la bien-pensance et de
l'angélisme cela pèse comme toujours au
final sur des Français qui subissent
l'insécurité au quotidien laissez-moi
maintenant vous parler d'un cas que je
connais bien sur mon territoire dans le
Loiret et qui Ulysse illustre toutes les
contradictions et injustices de votre
politique le 20 septembre 2020 Valentin
19 ans était fauché par un automobiliste
conduisant sous l'influence d'alcool et
de stupéfiants nous sommes le 25 octobre
2022 2 ans après et la procédure est
toujours en cours interminable ses
parents m'ont fait part de leur immense
chagrin de l'attente insoutenable d'un
jugement définitif et d'une réparation
qui ne sera jamais à l'auteur de leur
perte et pendant ce temps l'auteur des
faits est en liberté il a toujours son
permis et nargue les habitants de
Montargis dont les parents du petit
Valentin et sa petite sœur au volant de
son véhicule dans les rues plus occupé
depuis votre nomination à combattre le
rassemblement national qui a apporté des
réponses concrètes pour combattre la
délinquance et la criminalité dans notre
pays vous abdiquer une nouvelle fois
alors que l'insécurité vécue par nos
citoyens justifierait une réponse
judiciaire forte
ce budget révèle un projet politique
celui de l'impunité généralisée et du
permis de commettre des infractions au
fond ce budget dévoile une nouvelle
corde à votre arc la capacité de faire
moins bien avec pourtant plus ma
question est donc simple monsieur le
ministre qu'attendez-vous pour orienter
ces hausses de budget vers le
renforcement de la politique d'exécution
des peines de l'ensemble des délinquants
et quelques rendez-vous aussi pour
rompre avec le marqueur de votre
impuissance que constitue le déploiement
massif de ces peines alternatives je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
Coulomme pour le groupe la France
insoumise
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
vous évoquez avec fierté par ce projet
de loi une signification du budget de la
justice à hauteur de 711 millions
d'euros soit 8% de plus par rapport au
budget précédent tout d'abord au regard
de l'inflation vous ne pouvez
honnêtement vous prévaloir d'une telle
augmentation qui en ressort finalement
bien à moindre riz mais surtout le
rapport de la Commission européenne pour
l'efficacité de la justice qui vient
d'être publiée et sans appel la France
est encore à la traîne par rapport à nos
voisins européens puisqu'elles dépensent
72 euros par an et par habitant là où
l'Italie en dépense 82 l'Espagne 88 et
l'Allemagne 141
quant au nombre de magistrats par
habitant la France n'en disposera que de
11%.000 habitants là où l'Allemagne en
dépose en disposait du double ces
carences alarmantes sont le résultat de
budget insuffisants depuis des années et
que vous venez perpétuer avec celui que
vous nous présentez aujourd'hui un seul
exemple suffira à Monsieur le Ministre
pour montrer à quel point vous êtes
sinistrement déconnecté des besoins du
terrain duquel vous provenez pourtant
puisque le budget budget alloué à
l'administration pénitentiaire et
notamment dans l'investissement
immobilier pour la création de place de
prison est près de 8 fois plus élevé que
celui de l'accès aux droits et à la
justice et 4,5 fois plus élevé que celui
de la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse votre budget est donc porté sur
une politique carcérale et non sur
l'amélioration en profondeur de ce
service public en souffrance tant pour
les professionnels que pour les
justiciables en effet seulement 712
millions sont alloués au programme
d'accès aux droits dont l'aide
juridictionnelle qui n'augmente que de
4,2% contre 15% pour l'année dernière
vous éloignez davantage les justiciables
précaires pourtant les plus touchés par
ses besoins alors que tous les
professionnels sur le terrain
préconisent de prévoir l'élargissement
massif de ce budget indispensable en
termes d'accès aux droits des citoyens
et ce n'est qu'un exemple vous savez
peut-être que par un heureux hasard et
en total adéquation avec notre ordre du
jour nous avons visionné hier soir en
collaboration avec le barreau de Paris
le documentaire une justice à bout de
souffle qui est encore disponible
d'ailleurs sur tous les réseaux sociaux
et les plateformes de téléchargement et
comme vous ne pouvez décemment l'ignorer
les professionnels ici y sont unanimes
la justice va mal très mal et à ce que
vous nous proposez avec ce PLF relève de
l'indécence quand il est éloigné de la
réalité des besoins et
inadéquat face à l'urgence d'un
investissement massif dans ce service
public qui selon un peu plus chaque jour
je citerai simplement pour terminer la
question résonnante d'une greffière
abordant les suicides et les conditions
de travail déplorables habillement au
quotidien tout le qui tente coûte que
coûte de rendre une justice la plus
humaine possible combien voulez-vous de
morts voilà ces mots monsieur le
ministre il est plus que temps de cesser
cette politique d'investissement de
façade dans la justice et d'agir face à
la souffrance de ceux pour lesquelles
vous vous êtes engagés et dont vous
devez défendre la Creuse professionnelle
et justiciable merci
merci la parole de Monsieur Erwan Balan
pour le groupe démocrate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues c'est un budget
sans précédent de 9,6 milliards d'euros
un budget en hausse de 8% pour la
troisième année consécutive que vous
nous présentez ce sont 710 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qui viennent
participer au service public de la
justice nous pouvons le dire avec fierté
la justice se donne désormais les moyens
de son action mais le chemin reste long
temps l'administration judiciaire a été
lésée dans de nombreux pendant de
nombreuses années ce budget n'est donc
qu'une étape à valoriser c'est la raison
pour laquelle je tiens tout d'abord à
saluer les efforts qui sont faits pour
la justice judiciaire cela permet je
l'espère de contribuer au déploiement de
la loi du 22 décembre 2021 pour la
confiance de l'institution judiciaire et
de ses objectifs et cela devra aussi je
l'espère également permettre de donner
corps aux états généraux de la justice
ainsi que vous avez eu l'occasion de le
mentionner monsieur le ministre lors de
la dernière dans cette commission alors
je tiens à saluer la hausse
substantielle du budget de 33 millions
pour un total de 712,5 millions d'euros
à louer à l'accès aux droits accès
primordial pour tout un chacun quand il
est quand il est nécessaire à la
connaissance la promotion et la défense
de ses droits notamment pour les
victimes d'infraction pénales c'est
ainsi que dans cet esprit de performance
d'efficacité de refonte de l'institution
judiciaire vous mettez notamment
l'accent sur le suivi de l'évaluation
d'une réforme d'ampleur celle de la
justice pénale des mineurs alors que
nous venons de souffler la première
bougie du code de la justice pénale des
mineurs il a déjà su montrer son
efficacité rappelons en effet que jusque
l'année dernière la procédure judiciaire
et les délais de jugement pour les
mineurs n'étaient pas encadrés un mineur
était ainsi jugé en moyenne dans un
délai de 18 mois et 45% d'entre eux
avaient alors atteint la majorité
désormais de l'audience de culpabilité à
l'audience de sanction il ne s'écoule
plus que 8 à 9 mois en moyenne c'est
inédit et il ne faut évidemment pas se
reposer sur ces derniers sur ses
premiers succès vous annoncez en août
votre volonté de poursuivre l'évaluation
de cette réforme tant dans sa mise en
place en pratique que dans ses effets à
travers une trentaine d'indicateurs
nationaux et locaux mis en place dès
2022 qui permettent d'apprécier
l'application quantitative et
opérationnelle du code à chaque stade de
la procédure alors ma première question
est donc la suivante pourriez-vous
préciser de quelle manière en dehors de
ces indicateurs ses moyens alloués à
l'accompagnement de l'ensemble des
réformes de 2023 toucheront
toucheront-ils spécialement la justice
pénale des mineurs nous assurons ainsi
d'un déploiement efficace de ce nouveau
code
alors ma deuxième question elle concerne
une alerte et un avis qui nous a été
donné et aller plus technique un avis de
juillet 2021 la Défenseur des droits
auditionnée dans la commune dans cette
commission
sur la donc pardon la Défenseur des
droits auditionné par la mission
d'information sur le harcèlement
scolaire et le cyber-harcèlement a
révélé que les chefs d'établissement
étaient réticents à prendre en charge
des cas de harcèlement scolaire lorsque
les plaintes sont en cours d'enquête ou
étant où étaient classés sans suite
alors que même alors que ces deux
procédures sont complètement compatibles
et indépendantes je saisis cette
interrogation pour vous demander s'il ne
serait pas intéressant pour une
meilleure compréhension des droits de
nos droits de nos enfants d'accès en
tuer le partenariat entre la justice et
l'éducation nationale
merci Monsieur Yann Boucard pour le
groupe les républicains
merci à Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues monsieur
le garde des soirs récemment déclaré sur
un plateau de télévision la justice
c'est difficile à rendre et je le
rejoins totalement c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est important de lui donner
les moyens de ses ambitions dans ce
projet de loi de finance comme chaque
année la majorité présidentielle et le
gouvernement se félicite d'un budget de
la justice présenté comme exceptionnel
et historique alors qu'au fond chacun
sait ici que rien ne va changer
fondamentalement pour les justiciables
en 2023 la plupart de nos concitoyens
devront toujours attendre près de deux
années pour qu'une décision de justice
soit rendue et cela n'est pas acceptable
dans un pays comme la France il est vrai
que le budget de la justice augmente
chaque année tout comme le budget
général pas plus pas moins c'est
d'augmentation sera-t-elle suffisante
pour que la justice soit mieux rendue
assurément non malgré les hausses des
crédits intervenus ces dernières années
notre système judiciaire se dégrade
petit à petit en raison notamment de
crédit d'investissement qui ne peuvent
pas être dépensés en trois ans une année
complète de crédit n'a pas été dépensé
le covid n'explique et n'excuse pas tout
du programme de construction de prison
qui n'est pas réalisé 15000 places
étaient prévus le premier quinquennat
aujourd'hui ce chiffre a été ramené à
7000 places de prison d'ici à la fin de
l'année 2022 accompagné peut-être de
8000 places supplémentaires à l'horizon
2027 alors que nous arrivons à la fin la
première échéance seul 2081 place ont
été ouvertes ils devraient en avoir
seulement 2000 supplémentaires en 2023
avec la livraison de 10 nouveaux
établissements chacun constatera que le
contenu est pas nos prisons sont
délabrés indignes avec un taux
d'occupation qui ne fait qu'augmenter
passant de quasiment 120% en 2020 à 126
en 2021 et 2022 s'annonce encore plus
compliqué avec une estimation à 129%.
enfin le temps d'attente pour les
justiciables est insupportable le délai
moyen de traitement de la Cour de
cassation pour les affaires civiles et
passer de 17,9 mois 2020 à 19,1 en 2021
le délai moyen de traitement de la cour
d'appel et quant à lui de 17,5 mois 2021
alors qu'il était de 17 en 2020 il faut
donc en moyenne plus d'un an et demi
pour que ces juridictions prennent une
décision c'est lenteur était déjà
difficilement acceptable par le passé et
elles ne font qu'augmenter d'année en
année
il y a néanmoins des points positifs
dans ce projet de loi qu'il est
important de souligner notamment ce qui
concerne les créations d'emplois en 2023
le ministère bénéficiera ainsi de la
création de 2253 ETP qui va l'entente
plein 1220 judiciaires pour renforcer la
justice de proximité et résorber la
vacance d'emploi dans les greffes 809 de
l'administration pénitentiaire pour
l'ouverture de nouveaux établissements
pour développer la sécurité
pénitentielle et favoriser la
réinsertion et 92 créés pour la PSJ la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
notamment pour renforcer
l'accompagnement des jeunes qui lui sont
confiés et mettre en oeuvre la réforme
de la justice pénale des mineurs toutes
ces créations d'emplois sont une bonne
nouvelle et elles ne seront pas de trop
regarde de l'augmentation du nombre
d'affaires à juifs dans nos tribunaux de
la paupérisation dans nos prisons et du
manque de sécurité latent qui existent
en juin 2022 il y avait 241 361
personnes prises en charge par
l'administration pénitentiaire dont
71678 placés sous-écrou heureusement que
les 43000 agents des services militaires
dont près de 30500 personnes de
surveillance et 5000 personnels de SPIP
sont présents chaque jour pour
contribuer à la réinsertion et assurer
mesdames Cécile est un meilleur pour le
groupe socialiste
merci merci monsieur le Président comme
cela a été dit donc par les différents
orateurs le budget de la justice pour
s'inscrit dans la continuité d'un effort
significatif plus 8%
les États généraux ont donné finalement
le tempo d'une nécessité de maintenir un
effort budgétaire et sans doute plus
conséquent les citoyens aussi ont
désormais conscience d'une justice
maltraitée et nous attendent et nous
oblige je ferai deux observations un
commentaire et de questions deux
observations d'abord le rapport copège
maintient la France en dessous de la
moyenne européenne cela a été dit il
faut le rappeler c'est un c'est un
curseur que nous devons prendre en
compte ensuite cet effort budgétaire
n'est pas le plus remarquable je voulais
parler de celui du ministère de
l'intérieur avec 15 milliards qui dans
sa loi de programmation accentue
finalement le différentiel des plans de
charge respectives alors qu'on sait
combien justice et sécurité liberté
doivent fonctionner ensemble
alors mon observation c'est sur la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
nous avons un effort manifeste qui est
consenti pour la PJJ avec un budget de
916 millions 85 millions d'euros
d'augmentation avec au final 92 emplois
créant 2023 92 emplois seulement alors
que la réforme importante du code de
justice pénale des mineurs qui
forte heureusement semble aller dans le
bon sens et à nécessité des efforts des
équipes rassemblées
méritent d'être félicité et encouragé
moi il ressort des premières auditions
que nous avons menées avec mon collègue
Jean terrier que les capacités de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
pour répondre à cette réactivité
attendue pour réduire les délais n'est
pas aussi évidente qu'on pourrait le
croire c'est normal il faut changer les
pratiques et c'est en ce sens que nous
défendrons mon groupe des amendements
raisonnables de nature à donner plus de
souplesse et de souffle dans l'exercice
de leur mission
des postes supplémentaires nous
semble-t-il 50 pour permettre la
création de coordonnateurs de formateurs
et d'encadrement intermédiaire parce que
c'est cela qui nous a été proposé
ensuite des psychologues je voulais
attache appeler votre attention sur les
psychologues dans un moment où la
psychiatrie disparaît en France et en
particulier parce que la jeunesse
délinquante mérite ce soutien alors mes
deux questions la première c'est sur la
détention provisoire elle n'arrive pas à
diminuer on est toujours à 30% de
personnes détenues je sais vos efforts
en ce sens et votre résolution d'y
parvenir que doit-on faire pour cela
est-ce qu'il manque justement de ces
équipements et de ses alternatives et de
ses éducateurs qui seraient en capacité
de rassurer les juges dans des décisions
qui ne seraient pas celle de
l'enfermement et ma deuxième question
c'est sur le numérique parce que quel
que soit le crédit que nous mettrons en
place la question du numérique est tout
à fait centrale dans les tribunaux
judiciaire les logiciels on ne sait pas
pourquoi sont extrêmement lourds à
utiliser et ralentissent
considérablement le travail des juges
alors que lorsque l'on voit ce que fait
la Cour de cassation le Conseil d'État
avec les avocats au Conseil d'État et à
la Cour de cassation on s'aperçoit que
ils ont des logiciels tout à fait
performants donc il faut absolument
arriver à régler cette question et à ce
sujet je vous demande si vous avez
envisagé et mesurer toute l'importance
de ce sujet merci Monsieur Didier Le
Maire pour le groupe horizon
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues tout d'abord
permettez-moi de remercier les
différents rapporteurs Sarah tanzelli
Puya et Patrick etsel pour le travail
effectué le budget de cette mission vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre est en
hausse pour l'année 2023 cela constitue
une hausse de 26% du budget de la
justice en trois ans c'est important de
le souligner car cela est inédit depuis
plus depuis plus par nom de 25 ans
l'augmentation du budget de cette
mission poursuit trois objectifs majeurs
rendre une justice de qualité avec la
réduction des délais de traitement
particulièrement dans les contentieux du
divorce et pour les contentieux portés
devant le conseil des prud'hommes
renforcer l'efficacité de la réponse
pénale le sens et l'efficacité de la
peine
adaptée moderniser la justice en
renforçant l'accès des usagers à leur
dossier en ligne afin de le faire
baisser les frais de justice qui
continuent d'augmenter la part des
conciliations et la satisfaction sur la
qualité de l'accueil dans les tribunaux
cette augmentation des crédits se place
aussi en cohérence avec les axes
prioritaires des fondus par le
gouvernement à savoir le renforcement
des moyens humains l'amélioration des
conditions de détention le renforcement
de certaines politiques pénales
notamment la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales
nous avons en France un déficit de
greffier de greffière de magistrats et
de magistrates cette situation n'est
malheureusement pas exceptionnelle mais
bien commune à toutes les juridictions
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
dans le budget que vous soumettez à
notre examen je me réjouis donc de la
création de 10 000 emplois dont 2553 dès
et du doublement de l'enveloppe
consacrée aux mesures catégorielles soit
80 millions d'Euros pour renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers
l'ensemble de la masse salariale or
contribution au compte d'affectation
spéciale pension progresse de 440
millions d'euros c'est une bonne chose
et se situe dans la continuité de
l'action menée par le gouvernement
ceux-ci depuis 2017
monsieur le ministre quand on sait que
notre pays comprend plus de 600
juridictions je parle des tribunaux
judiciaires des tribunaux de commerce
des tribunaux de proximité des conseils
de prud'hommes des tribunaux du travail
du tribunal supérieur d'appel de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon des cour
d'appel et de la Cour de cassation
pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît nous
détailler la répartition de ces
créations d'emplois
savez-vous d'ores et déjà dans quel
juridiction et ou quel service et sur
quel territoire ces nouveaux emplois
seront affectés
et dans quel délai
je l'ai évoqué un peu plus tôt le
gouvernement souhaite renforcer
certaines politiques pénales dont la
lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales
c'est indispensable
en effet aujourd'hui en France à l'heure
actuelle ce sont 89 femmes qui sont
mortes sous les coups de leur compagnon
ou ex compagnons
dans ma circonscription du Haut-Rhin que
j'ai l'honneur de représenter au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale les violences
intra-familiales sont en hausse
les violences conjugales et
intrafamilales sont alors actuelles
encore trop peu fréquemment suivi de
plainte en particulier lorsqu'il
lorsqu'il s'agit d'agression à caractère
sexuel aussi je me réjouis que le budget
consacré au frais de justice connaît une
os de 12 millions d'euros en 2023 et
espère que cela encourage les victimes à
agir contre leur bourreaux en conclusion
le groupe horizon votera en faveur des
crédits de ces missions je vous remercie
merci Monsieur jérémyordanov pour le
groupe écologiste
merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues
j'ai bien noté que les crédits de la
mission justice augmentait cette année
malheureusement le volontarisme que vous
affichez ne suffira pas à combler
l'immense retard que nous avons accumulé
depuis de trop nombreuses années car
vous le savez nous partons de très loin
le personnel est à bout il n'a plus les
moyens de rendre une justice de qualité
les injustices civile et débordée les
cabinets des juges pour enfants sont
saturés les procureurs sont en sous
effectif les cadences sont infernales la
perte de sens est totale
au niveau européen la France et dans les
dernières places s'agissant des budgets
attribués à la justice
l'Allemagne contre deux contes deux fois
plus de juge que la France deux fois
plus de procureurs d'avocats de
greffiers même constat pour le budget
général de fonctionnement de la justice
la France dépense 70 euros par habitant
quand l'Allemagne en dépense 130
sans atteindre de tels écarts l'Espagne
l'Italie la Belgique font mieux que nous
la situation des parquets est encore
plus défavorable trois procureurs pour
100000 habitants en France contre un peu
plus de 5 en Espagne 7 en Allemagne 8 en
Belgique
le résultat de ce manque
d'investissement c'est l'allongement
sans fin des délais de jugement le
recours à la justice est devenu un
véritable parcours du combattant les
requérants ne sont plus écoutés les
juges des affaires familiales sont trop
souvent contraints de traiter chaque
dossier de divorce ou de séparation en
15 minutes et de ne pas donner la parole
au couple pour ne pas perdre de temps
quant au juge des enfants ils sont
condamnés à renouveler les mesures de
suivi éducatif sans voir les familles
parce que le nombre de dossiers à gérer
ne permet pas de les recevoir toutes
quant au délai de jugement ils sont
scandaleusement long en première
instance ou civil un dossier est
instruit en 220 jours en moyenne en
Allemagne il faut compter 420 jours en
France
face à cette justice en crise face à
l'urgence dans laquelle nous sommes les
mesures que vous annoncez pour cette
année ne sont pas à la hauteur
c'est trop peu vous les présidents des
tribunaux demandent 1500 magistrats
immédiatement par sur cinq ans et ça a
été dit 200 sur 2023 ça n'est pas
suffisant même constat pour l'équipe
autour du magistrat le juge a besoin de
greffier mais aussi de juristes
assistants là aussi les effectifs et les
revalorisations que vous annoncez ne
sont pas à la hauteur il faut recruter
davantage de greffiers pour que leur
charge de travail soit raisonnable avec
un ratio minimum de 2 greffiers pour un
magistrat il faut aussi rendre leurs
fonctions plus attractive en mêlera
améliorant leur statut leur rémunération
et les perspectives d'évolution
le rapport lotint du 12 octobre dernier
vous y invite en vous recommandant de
faire passer tous les greffiers en
catégorie A
il faut aussi revaloriser la condition
des juristes assistants qui doivent
pouvoir bénéficier d'un statut pérenne
et attractif ils sont aujourd'hui
recrutés pour 3 ans renouvelables une
fois l'absence de perspective à long
terme les incitent à chercher un emploi
plus stable même lorsqu'ils sont
épanouis dans leur mission
c'est un frein à l'attractivité de leur
fonction monsieur le ministre malgré des
efforts notables votre budget reste en
dessous des besoins et ne résout pas à
lui seul les grandes difficultés
auxquelles fait face la justice de notre
pays je vous remercie
merci Madame Emeline cabidi pour le
groupe gauche-démocrate et républicaine
merci monsieur le président
je suis le garde des sceaux le ministère
dont vous avez la charge crêpe de
partout manque chronique de moyens
humains et financier manque de
considération cela fait de trop
nombreuses années que la justice est
délaissée par les pouvoirs publics ce
n'est pas de votre seul fait je vous le
conseille mais c'est bien à vous qu'il
appartient désormais de proposer un
budget à la hauteur des enjeux rappelons
que le rapport de la Commission
européenne pour l'efficacité de la
justice du 5 octobre dernier confirme
que la France continue de figurer parmi
les pays qui a PIB comparable
investissent le moins dans leur justice
les conséquences de ce manque de moyens
sont terribles tant pour les
professionnels de la justice juge
greffiers personnel pénitentiaire avocat
que pour les justiciables par exemple
les délais de traitement des affaires
Baptiste ne se sous-investissement en
moyenne un dossier en premier instance
pour une procédure civile et résolue en
637 jours en France contre 237 jours
dans le reste de l'Europe la hausse du
budget que vous annoncez plus 8% par
rapport à 2022 est un début mais elle
nous paraît encore trop faible au vu des
besoins d'autant qu'une large partie de
celle-ci va être absorbée par
l'administration pénitentiaire
mes collègues qui ont pris la parole
avant moi ont pointé du doigt les
insuffisances de ce budget il y a un
point que je souhaiterais aborder en
particulier suite de la dotation
annuelle de la juridictionnelle elle est
largement insuffisante cette année dans
le barreau où j'exerce elle était
épuisée depuis le mois de juin dès le
mois de juin et une dotation
complémentaire qui nous a été apportée a
été épuisée ensuite dès le mois de
septembre la modification des critères
d'accès à l'aide juridictionnelle semble
en être la cause mais c'est surtout
l'augmentation de la pauvreté en France
qui entraîne une demande plus importante
de cette aide pour 2023 le budget
accordé à la juridictionnelle augmente
de 4,20% par rapport à 2022 c'est un bon
début mais cela nous paraît encore très
insuffisant la pauvreté en France
explose 12 millions de personnes vivent
désormais en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté ce qui représente 18,46% de la
population selon le 16e baromètre Ipsos
Secours populaire français du 6
septembre dernier à La Réunion où je
suis élu le taux de personnes vivant en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté s'élève à
20%
et l'augmentation de la demande d'aide
juridictionnelle doit donc être
concomitante de cette réalité mais dans
les différents critères d'analyse de
votre ministère ne figure pas la
pauvreté pour évaluer le besoin en
dotation d'aide juridictionnelle pas de
motion pas de mention de l'explosion de
cette pauvreté pas de prise en compte
des conséquences directes qu'elle pourra
entraîner
pas de projection donc sur
l'augmentation des demandes d'aide
juridictionnelle qui devra en résulter
nous craignons donc que l'augmentation
des dotations pour 2023 soit bien en
deçà de ce qu'il faudrait mais à l'image
finalement de l'ensemble des lignes de
ce budget en conclusion
je voudrais formuler une inquiétude
monsieur le ministre le budget que vous
nous présentez est encore très
insuffisant regardez besoin et des
objectifs affichés et je crains que pour
compenser cette insuffisance vous ne
décidiez dans un projet un prochain
projet de loi de réforme de la justice
de généraliser quelques procédures
complexes et inadaptées qui viennent
encore éloigner le justicier de la
justice ou diminuer le nombre d'affaires
traitées à grands coups de caducité
nudités il recevabilité le besoin de
justice est toujours plus important dans
notre société où les inégalités se
creusent dans un contexte de crise
sanitaire sociale économique et
énergétique sur le ministre votre budget
n'est pas à la hauteur des besoins ses
besoins vont-ils être pris en compte
pour mettre le budget à la hauteur des
objectifs que vous affichez
merci d'avoir été Monsieur Jean-François
Jean-Philippe Jean-Philippe pardon pour
le groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoires excusez-moi pour avoir
raccroché votre prénom
il y a pas de mal monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs
il n'est pas possible de nier les
efforts budgétaires conséquents actés en
2023 de ce budget avec 8 % en un an
cependant notre groupe est partagé
puisque force de constater que nous
sommes qu'à plusieurs niveaux les
résultats ne sont pas au rendez-vous
le problème nous semble pas être
uniquement allié à une question de
crédit mais un changement de paradigme
sur la question de la crise de
recrutement qui frappe le système
judiciaire notre groupe relève l'écart
entre les annonces de communication et
les faits alors que la première ministre
de son discours de politique générale
annonçait 3000 créations de postes
répartises à égalité entre magistrats et
greffier le budget 2023 nous semble loin
de ce compte on peut ainsi noter la
création de seulement je mettrai des
guillemets 200 postes de magistrats
pourquoi alors reporter à demain voir à
la fin du quinquennat les efforts pour
atteindre ces 1500 recrutement alors que
les tensions sur le juridiction
judiciaire sont pressentes en outre
notre groupe s'interroge s'agit-il de
création de postes immédiat dès 2023
dans la juridiction ou seulement de
places supplémentaires à l'École
Nationale de magistrature
c'est le crise impact directement le
principal indicateur de la mission la
durée de traitement des affaires
judiciaires aussi vite comme au pénal
depuis la pandémie le stock ne diminue
pas au point il devient difficile de
rendre justice dans un délai raisonnable
pour les justiciables outre les
inégalités qui en découlent la France
s'expose à de nouvelles condamnation
européenne pour ces délaisses excessifs
en ce sens le rapport sur les états
généraux de la justice de juillet
dernier prévoit comme piste
d'amélioration de renforcer l'entourage
du magistrat cela déjà été dit on a
aussi l'attractivité des emplois nous
semble au point mort ainsi les greffiers
manquent encore à l'appel en dépit des
crédits additionnels mobilisés comment
expliquer que le taux de vacances des
postes de greffiers progresse et s'élève
à 7,2% soit une hausse de 2,7 points par
rapport au niveau de 2019 quels sont les
pistes explorées par le ministère pour
pallier ce manque
sur la question des prisons là encore
notre groupe ne remet pas en cause la
volonté de l'exécutif il y a des moyens
avec 650 millions d'euros pour les
investissements immobiliers notamment
dans le cadre du Plan prison cependant
les indicateurs restent dans le rouge le
taux d'occupation des places en maison
d'arrêt a dépasser les 130% en 2023
contre 119 % en 2020 donc on s'interroge
concrètement quels sont les projections
d'évolution pour ce taux d'occupation
carcérale enfin notre groupe s'inquiète
également des faibles recrutements dans
l'administration pénitentiaire chaque
année les créations sont annoncées
semblent favorables comme c'est le cas
en 2023 avec plus 89 postes je crois
mais ces chiffres ne sont bons que sur
le papier pour l'heure comment expliquer
que ces prévisions soient atteintes
d'une sous-exécution chronique au-delà
des efforts en termes de rémunération
quelles sont les moyens déployés pour
renforcer l'attractivité du métier qui
évidemment souffre d'une image peut
favorable s'agissant de la seule
disposition législative rattachée notre
groupe demande des déséclaircissements
sur la troisième demande de prolongation
de l'expérimentation de la médiation
préalable pour les affaires familiales
depuis 2016 le gouvernement n'a pour
l'instant déployé le dispositif que dans
11 juridictions la pandémie ne semble
pas seulement être la seule cause pour
justifier ce retard on s'interroge
également sur son financement
l'évaluation préalable évoque un coût
total le 7,7 milliards sur 2023 donc
seulement 2,8 pour l'État en réalité le
coût pèse essentiellement au top 75% sur
les caves comment le ministère peut-il
prolonger avant d'avoir obtenu les
garanties que les caves poursuivront ce
modèle de financement voilà
quelques-unes des questions que le
groupe souhaite vous adresser monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole pour répondre à ces premières
questions
bon merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
donc d'abord
répondre à Madame la rapporteur pour
avis madame tanzili qui m'a posé
d'ailleurs beaucoup de questions à vrai
dire
la première étant relative à la
revalorisation des greffiers
c'est 10 millions d'augmentation
indemnités et une revalorisation
statutaire voilà la réponse que je peux
faire
pour être à la fois complet sans être
trop long
s'agissant des administrateurs haddocks
le ministère travaille à une réforme de
leur mission et de leur tarification
on souhaite qu'il y ait un
administrateur Adobe je l'indique
auprès de chaque enfant qui se présente
à
que l'on souhaite créer
il nous en faudrait un par deux pas un
par département en réalité sont des
endroits absolument essentiels à mes
yeux qui permettent de de soigner
l'enfant de le prendre en charge d'un
point de vue médical d'un point de vue
sanitaire psychologique psychiatrique
évidemment
et tout cela se fait pour éviter que
l'enfant qui a été victime soit amenée
soit conduit à répéter à plusieurs
reprises un certain nombre de choses et
on veut qu'il est assez coté un
administrateur ado qu'on envisage
d'ailleurs je vous l'indique si vous
avez des idées je suis preneur ne
changez le nom parce qu'on trouve
qu'administrateur Adobe pour un petit
enfant c'est compliqué on a pensé à un
par un judiciaire mais toutes les idées
sont bonnes à prendre évidemment
financement de la campagne de
sensibilisation sur les victimes
sexuelles commisses sur mineurs oui
madame la rapporteur s'est prévu au sein
du gypse dédié en 2023 c'est un sujet
qui est absolument prioritaire vu le
nombre de mineurs victimes environ 160
000 par an
vous avez évoqué également l'accès des
greffier à la magistrature à vous savez
qu'il y a deux voies ouvertes au
greffiers pour être nommés auditeur et à
le concours interne je vais vous donner
les chiffres pour 2019 c'est si greffier
sur les 29 lauréats
2021-11 greffiers sur les 48 lauréens et
il existe aussi une possibilité
d'intégration directe et dans le cadre
des États généraux ont réfléchit mieux
structurer l'équipe autour du magistrat
ça je peux vous dire que c'est une idée
qui a fait son chemin et qui est une
idée très consensuelle en créant un
corps de catégorie A auquel les
greffiers s'il le souhaite et s'ils en
ont des compétences pourront avoir accès
mais encore interrogé quand j'ai dit
qu'il y avait plusieurs questions c'est
vrai qu'il y avait plusieurs questions
sur le bracelet anti rapprochement
bon le sujet voulait parfaitement
identifié les services travaillent pour
que les alarmes utiles remontent et tout
à l'heure on m'a reproché une absence de
pilotage parce qu'il y avait eu des
difficultés techniques bon c'est une
façon de voir les choses dès que nous
avons eu connaissance des difficultés
techniques nous avons en réalité changer
de
pardon non m'échappe à cet instant de
prestataire et je peux vous dire que les
prestataires ont été reçus oui il y a
quelques jours je regrette presque
monsieur bernalicis que vous n'auriez
pas été présent vous auriez vu ce qu'est
un ministre directif voilà parce que je
veux que ça marche évidemment le bras
non non
vous aurez la parole après vous direz
tout le mal que vous pensiez du bracelet
anti rapprochement du nouveau
prestataire mais moi je vais vous dire
je peux vous dire et du gouvernement ça
ça c'est inutile de le dire c'est
pléonasmique pardonnez-moi et donc pour
être pour être plus sérieux évidemment
on a fait les réunions avec les
associations de victimes pour dire un
certain nombre de choses et et porter je
le dis un certain nombre d'exigences
très précises bon
[Musique]
rapporteur pour avis
on a engagé plusieurs actions pour
accompagner l'évolution des missions qui
sont confiées aux agents travaillant
dans les epip
1500 recrutements depuis 2018 et ça a
permis de diminuer le nombre de dossiers
suivis par Jean on est passé de 82 6
suivis à 71 et puis on a mis en place
des organigrammes de référence qui sont
de vrais outils on essaie de disent
qu'ils sont extrêmement utiles en termes
de revalorisation les cépips ont eu
plusieurs avancées importantes passages
en catégorie 1 revalorisation
indemnitaires 220 euros par mois en 2022
et vous m'interrogez évidemment à juste
titre sur ce que le ministère compte
faire pour rendre le métier de dépit
plus attractifs alors il est vrai que
des réformes interministérielles ont été
engagées depuis 2017 elles ont abouti à
revaloriser les salaires des conseillers
pénitentiaires d'insertion de probation
mais pas ceux des directeurs et il en
est de même pour les directeurs de
service de la PJJ alors concernant les
dépips parce que c'est votre question le
ministère s'engage en 2022 revalorisé
les primes de dépip d'environ 700 000
euros qui viennent s'ajouter aux 600 000
euros octroyés à ce corps en 2021 et en
2023 je veux porter la poursuite de la
hausse des primes à hauteur d'un million
une réforme du statut pour faciliter la
promotion professionnelle et les
parcours de carrière plus attractifs ils
revalorisation de leur rémunération
indiciaire à hauteur de
1,3 millions sur la question de la
libération sous contrainte de plein
droit
je précise que 30 postes seront créés au
PDF 2023 auquel s'ajoutent les 70 postes
affectés en renfort des pôles placements
sous surveillance électronique en 2022
monsieur monsieur Etzel monsieur vous
vous
m’exhortez à réalisme
faut que je descende de
je ne sais quelle planète où je serai
perdu
oui mon galaxy si vous voulez je
voudrais d'abord vous dire quelque chose
de très simple
quand je dis 30 ans d'abandon humain
budgétaire politique
je pense aussi à vous
soyons clairs
soyons clairs quand nous nous avons
embauché plus de 700 magistrats et qui a
une époque le chiffre était négatif
parce qu'on remplaçait pas les départs à
la retraite je sais pas lequel de nous
deux était à l'époque le plus réaliste
mais franchement la question se pose
maintenant c'est toujours bien
de tirer l'attention d'un ministre et de
le faire redescendre sur terre si tenter
qu'il ait eu envie de s'envoler ce qui
n'est pas mon cas je vous rassure alors
maintenant on va quand même redire les
choses je le dis à tout le monde
d'ailleurs parce que la critique est
facile l'art est un peu plus difficile
mais pardon
on parle ici d'un budget pas du tonneau
des Danaïdes donc moi aussi j'aimerais
vous dire mais si j'en avais plus bien
sûr mais 15 monsieur Hugo
bernalicis Hugo à Beauvau et quand c'est
le truc là après
on essaie d'être entre gens sérieux je
vais quand même vous dire quelque chose
moi aussi moi aussi moi aussi voilà
c'est parti
voilà moi aussi j'aime j'aimerais vous
dire et pourquoi pas plus et ce serait
mieux je veux d'ailleurs vous dire que
certains de ceux qui me disent ça n'est
pas assez n'ont pas voté les budgets de
l'année dernière l'essuie de l'année
d'avant d'ailleurs quand même fabuleux
ça d'entendre ça parce que j'entends ça
n'est qu'un début ça n'est qu'un début
bon je vous réponds monsieur je ne vous
ai pas oublié mais je veux quand même
vous dire que moi vous voyez ça c'est du
réalisme
mathématiques arithmétique moins c'est
pas égal à plus voilà et que vous le
vouliez ou non la justice vous voyez il
reste beaucoup de choses à faire n'a
jamais été budgétairement aussi bien
doté que depuis que le Président de la
République
et président de la République que vous
le vouliez ou non ces comparaisons elles
vous font mal je les dis tout à l'heure
les mots on peut en faire ce qu'on en
veut mais les chiffres c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué alors nous voyez dans ce
qui reste à faire et il reste beaucoup
de choses à faire je dis avec une
humilité qui n'est pas finte je pense
qu'on a fait beaucoup de choses je pense
qu'on peut être fier d'un certain nombre
de choses qui ont été faites mais il
reste des choses à faire je l'ai
toujours dit alors
1500 magistrats de plus c'est pas rien
1500 fonctionnaires de greffe de plus ça
n'est pas rien mis en place d'une équipe
autour du magistrat ça n'est pas rien et
un effort dès 2023 de sans création
nette de poste de magistrats promotion
historique de l'École nationale de la
magistrature vous pouvez toujours dire
que je fais rien que je dors que je
devrais me préoccuper d'autre chose que
de certains d'entre vous mais enfin
cette promotion historique c'est nous
qui en sommes à l'origine voilà 1000
créations de postes de fonctionnaires
contractuels
greffier 400 juristes assistants
429 autres postes oui à cela s'ajouter
la pérennisation de 650 postes de
contractuels obtenus dès 2022 et dont je
reparlerai bon recruter ça implique
forcément renforcement des qualités des
capacités de formation ça ne peut pas se
faire en un claquement de doigt on me
dit mais pourquoi pas tout de suite mais
il faut les former ou est-ce que je l'ai
fait dans les algeco qui était
parmi les les projets présidentiels de
certains ou de certaines enfin ça n'est
pas sérieux ça n'est pas sérieux moi je
n'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir tout réglé
mais nous avons réglé un certain nombre
de choses
et nous allons régler un certain nombre
de choses le maître mot d'ailleurs des
états généraux de la justice c'est
effectivement la prime des magistraux
monsieur Excel c'est le contraire ma
volonté cette valoriser davantage les
jeunes magistrats aux alentours de 1300
euros et moins les anciens voyez-vous ce
que je pense que sont les jeunes qui ont
peut-être besoin d'un coup de main d'un
coup de main supplémentaire je l'indique
d'ailleurs c'est curieux que dans
l'expression syndicale un syndicat a dit
c'est notre victoire je me suis permis
de leur dire très aimablement que moi je
ne m'étais félicité que des
acquittements que j'avais plaidé on
m'avait rien demandé c'est tombé en
additionne notre victoire mais tant
mieux puis les autres ont dit c'est pas
notre souci je leur ai d'ailleurs
suggéré de donner cet argent une
association caritative je ferme là
encore la parenthèse sur le taux de
vacances des magistrats je vais vous
dire on va regarder très précisément les
chiffres elle était de 5,77% au 1er
septembre 2017 et de 0,58% au 1er
septembre 2021 alors c'est remonter un
peu c'est vrai au 1er septembre 2022
vous voyez que je suis réaliste et j'ai
les pieds sur terre en raison des
créations budgétaires massives de poste
dont bénéficient ministère pour lesquels
les recrutements vont s'accélérer en
voilà au fond les raisons madame la
députée Caroline Abadie
je sais à quel point votre
investissement est
[Musique]
impressionnant je le dis NON je cherche
mon mot parce que ça n'est pas rien ce
que vous faites
au quotidien c'est une des spécialistes
de la prison vous en parlez d'ailleurs
avec beaucoup de nuances vous pourriez
de vous pourriez de ce point de vue
tenter de de transmettre cette nuance
parce que on ne peut pas évoquer ces
sujets dans une espèce de de manichéisme
très facile au fond intellectuellement
très facile voilà ceci étant dit je
j'essaie de répondre aux questions que
vous me posez d'abord
2023 alors 2022 4 établissements vont
être livrés connaît dans la province
province Nord de Nouvelle-Calédonie
trois structures d'accompagnement vers
la sortie quand Montpellier quand manque
2023 10 établissements vont être livrés
j'ai passé mon été à visiter les
chantiers bon puis j'ai mis comment le
dire
j'ai dit deux jours trois choses au
patron de la pige parce que je veux que
nous soyons en rendez-vous de nos
engagements c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça il y a des années maintenant puisque
maintenant
c'est un pluriel qu'on me dit mais ces
prisons et c'est prison elle sortent
elle sorte et députés qui veulent venir
avec moi
viendront les députés durs rassemblement
national d'ailleurs était là quand j'ai
visité à Toulon La Farlède où il y a une
SAS qui est en construction ils ont pu
témoigner de ça je ne sais pas s'ils le
feront mais enfin c'est une réalité
voilà coup prévisionnel total du
programme 15000 c'est
4,5 milliards d'euros et je veux dire
quelque chose là-dessus là vous voyez
il y a selon les sensibilités politiques
certains qui souhaiteraient moins de
budget pour la pénitentiaire au profit
du judiciaire et d'autres qui pensent
qu'il faut construire des places moi je
vais vous dire quelque chose j'ai
entendu un raisonnement assez singulier
qu'on entend très souvent
qui est assez simple pour ne pas dire
simpliste on dit mais plus vous
construisez de prison
et voilà vous finissez la phrase et plus
vous les remplissez oui
mais alors comment on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors on se suit pas de
prison ouais mais alors on fait quoi en
terme de dignité de la détention en
termes de réponses en termes de en
termes de réponse pénale qu'est-ce que
on libère ah oui on libère voilà ça mais
mesdames messieurs du rassemblement
national c'est du laxisme oui
mais non mais
si si si si si c'est ça mais enfin
peut-être sérieux non
vous êtes bien gentil vous êtes bien
gentil plus on les remplit alors plus on
en construit plus on est rempli et donc
et donc on en construit plus et donc
comment on règle la difficulté qui est
celle de nos prisons indignes bon
d'accord d'accord très bien très bien
alors
c'est parfait la répartition des
effectifs des j c'est une des questions
vous me posez
2023 c'est 2253 à comparer à environ 720
pour 2022 ils sont répartis de la façon
suivante
1220 DJ à savoir 200 magistrats 91
métiers du greffe cette 575 personnels
d'encadrement 254 administratifs et
techniques 809 Dappes
92 PJJ 132 SG ensuite vous m'avez
interrogé sur la tige et cette ce
partenariat région
partons de dire que je peux pas vous en
dire davantage puisque c'est géré par
les régions aujourd'hui
et notamment sur les questions
pécuniaires que vous évoquez mais je
dois dire qu'on est extrêmement vigilant
et extrêmement attentif évidemment ce
qui se fait
et pour moi la formation personne la
formation professionnelle en détention
d'absolument essentielle comme le
travail en détention d'ailleurs je pense
que c'est une des clés c'est une des
clés de la réinsertion et je veux dire à
certains qui racontent en permanence que
Yaka faut qu'on faudrait il y avait peu
de monde au balcon quand il s'est agit
notamment de voter le contrat du détenu
travailleur 1 peu demande au balcon
c'est gentil de dire il fait rien ils
font rien nous on ferait nous on
réglerait tout mais enfin moi j'ai quand
même vous dire ce que c'est ce contrat
du détenu travailleur parce que j'en
suis pas peu fier voyez-vous c'est 45%
du SMIC c'est les charges sociales qui
sont prises en charge les droits sociaux
pris en charge par nous
c'est les formalités administratives qui
sont prises en charge par nous ça permet
aux patrons de de d'avoir un coût de
production qui est inférieur
naturellement mais aussi d'offrir du
travail d'offrir de la formation et ça
permet aussi de rembourser
et de payer les victimes qui sont mieux
indemnisées grâce à cet argent qui
provient du salaire mais je trouve que
voyez-vous la boucle elle est cinq fois
vertueuse et que ça mérite d'être dit
bon alors maintenant
on arrive aux questions qui m'ont été
aimablement posées par le rassemblement
national
alors je vais essayer de vous redire un
certain nombre de choses mais
j'espère que vous les entendez d'abord
en terme de laxisme je veux vous
rappeler que sous la droite classique
vous aviez voté
non je dis classique au sens premier du
terme c'est un compliment vous aviez
voté
des aménagements de peine jusqu'à deux
ans d'emprisonnement
nous avons réduit un an c'est nous qui
l'avons fait c'est nous qui l'avons fait
deuxièmement
deuxièmement le rappel à la loi monsieur
le député informez-vous il est supprimé
en fait non un Sicile s'y connaît c'est
l'avertissement pénal probatoire ce qui
n'a mais je sais ce qui n'a particulu et
qui n'a strictement rien à voir bon
ensuite pardonnez-moi mais vous me
parlez du programme présidentiel de
Madame Le Pen alors je voudrais vous
dire
non non je vais me faire plaisir pardon
monsieur vous savez on est tenu parce
que l'on dit
on ressemble à ce que l'on dit
d'ailleurs elle souhaitait 9000
magistrats nous avions déjà largement et
allègrement passer ce chiffre ce qui
prouve l'intérêt qu'elle porte au sujet
justice elle voulait une peine de
perpétuité réelle elle doit exister
depuis des temps mémoriaux dans notre
code pénal et d'ailleurs c'est la
sanction c'est la sanction qui a été
infligée dans le procès-vet 13 un
monsieur Abdeslam Salah elle voulait
encore disait-elle des courtes peines
susceptibles comme aux Pays-Bas 2 c'est
exactement le contraire au Pays-Bas ils
ont renoncé ou courte peine parce que ça
marche pas et vous nous avez menti
pendant toute la campagne ou alors ou
alors vous n'avez pas fait ce que j'ai
fait c'est à dire par exemple joindre un
magistrat néerlandais qui connaissait
question moi j'ai la chance d'avoir un
magistrat de liaison vous étiez dans un
mensonge permanent maintenant on va
aller plus loin parce que c'est
insupportable voyez la façon dont vous
abordez le sujet justice
que vous racontiez de moi ce que vous
voulez j'en accepte l'ogre mais quand
même je vais vous donner quelques
chiffres clés
entre 2001 et 2020
entre 2001 et 2020 en matière criminelle
comme en matière délictuelle on
enregistre une hausse de la sévérité des
peines prononcées que vous le vouliez au
pain vous pouvez vous arrêter sur telle
affaire sur tel autre vous avez le droit
de faire ça mais il y a des milliers de
décisions qui sont rendus dans notre
pays on ne peut pas s'arrêter sur une
affaire dont je conçois qu'elle peut
nous choquer d'ailleurs voyez moi j'ai
mis en place la justice filmée c'est
justement pour que l'on comprenne à quel
point il est difficile voyez-vous de
prononcer une peine à quel point la
personnalisation de la peine est
importante à quel point dans un jury
populaire
mesdames et messieurs les députés
certains peuvent penser qu'une peine est
sévère et d'autres peuvent penser
qu'elle est trop clémente mais retenez
qu'entre 2001 et 2020 en matière
criminelle matière criminelle c'est nos
compatriotes qui fixent le quantum de la
peine c'est le jury populaire bien
deuxièmement la fréquence du prononcé de
l'emprisonnement ferme étant hausse
entre 2002
et 2005 l'emprisonnement était prononcé
dans 20% des condamnations
59% en cas récidive entre 2016 et 2019
l'emprisonnement est prononcé dans 27%
des condamnations et dans 68% des cas en
matière de récidive près de
près de sancelle 116.000 peines dans
président de montfer ont été prononcés
en 2010 120000 en 2015 132
000 en 2019 et puis ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous me
reprochez à la fois le laxisme de la
justice en oubliant que le garde des
sceaux ne peut pas donner de directives
que les magistrats et fort heureusement
dans ce pays sont totalement
indépendants et en même temps vous me
reprochez la surpopulation carcérale
c'est quand même absolument
extraordinaire et puis j'ai quand même
vous dire le attendez c'est pas fini
souffrez souffrez que je réponde à ces
questions
de 2009 à 2021 le taux de poursuite
c'est accrue de près de points le nombre
de classements s'ensuit pour
inopportunité des poursuites à diminuer
de
552 précisément à 173000
999 alors vous arrêtez sur tel à faire
ou sur tel autre l'affaire dans un
phénomène que j'appelle la fait
diversification de la justice là vous
pousser des cris d'orfray c'est
naturellement le garde des sceaux le
gouvernement qui est responsable de tout
et vous vous avez trouvé la solution
Beccaria mais vous avez mille fois
raison c'est un grand humanisme et
l'humanisme c'est tellement important
monsieur le député quand on parle de
justice mais permettez-moi de vous dire
là encore que vous nous donnez des
chiffres qui sont faux en termes
d'exécution moi je vais vous donner les
vrais chiffres ce que vous ne voulez pas
ah non mais monsieur monsieur moi vous
m'avez branché sur un sujet vous voyez
que je connais bien que j'ai la
faiblesse de bien connaître alors vous
n'allez pas vous en sortir là maintenant
on n'est pas au QG là on a pas deux
minutes vous allez entendre ce que ce ce
ce que je vous dis
il y a une hausse de 35% de la
population détenue 7,8 points de
pourcentage supérieur à la hausse du
nombre de places opérationnelles alors
maintenant maintenant
les peines fermes prononcées par les
tribunaux correctionnels sont exécutés à
72% dans un délai d'un an
85% dans un délai de deux ans 91%
au-delà je trouve que c'est trop j'y
travaille nous avons diminué déjà le
délai mais je vais vous expliquer
quelque chose les peines qui ne sont pas
exécutées ça n'est pas un stock de peine
morte monsieur le député je vous
explique
le mandat de dépôt à l'audience c'est
l'exécution immédiate on est d'accord
vous êtes condamné monsieur à trois ans
d'emprisonnement faire et mandat de
dépôt le type est menotté il part tout
de suite exécution immédiate en revanche
une peine aménageable pour qu'elle soit
exécutée on doit réunir le juge
d'application des peines et les cpips
dont on vient de parler qui font un
boulot absolument formidable il faut
faire des enquêtes voir la faisabilité
voir si le type a un domicile une ligne
enfin tout ça ça prend un peu de temps
et ce temps-là c'est un temps de non
exécution mais dès que cette peine est
exécutée je le concède dans un délai
trop long parce que la justice manque
encore de moyens alors arrive d'autres
peines et le stock n'est pas un stock de
peine morte vous racontez ça sur tous
les plateaux de télé c'est un mensonge
où c'est une méconnaissance au mieux
c'est une méconnaissance on peut
toujours s'informer au pire c'est un
mensonge et ses politiquesment très
grave
voilà
sans
600.613 semaines d'emprisonnement ferme
étaient en attente d'exécution en
décembre 2020 il s'agit principalement
de courtes peines
97% de ces peines sont aménageables
le stock de peine d'emprisonnement ferme
en attente d'exécution ne constitue pas
un stock figé entendez le une fois pour
toute il faut du temps pour réunir le CP
pour réunir le juge d'application des
peines et pendant ce temps-là il y a un
temps de latence ou bien sûr les choses
ne sont pas exécutées voilà la réalité
94% allez comparer avec les autres pays
européens et vous verrez qu'on n'a pas à
rougir des chiffres qui sont les nôtres
qui t'ont si vous le voulez bien
les bancs de l'extrême droite pour
répondre maintenant à monsieur le député
Jean-François Colomb
comment Monsieur pardonnez-moi je le dis
il y a mille façons de se respecter
pouvez-vous me demander
combien de morts il faudra pour que je
réagisse
vous avez transmis quoi
moi je vous remercie
d'organiser le débat entre vous mais
répondez jusqu'au bout monsieur le
ministre on n'est pas on n'est pas
obligé de relire on n'est pas obligé de
tout relayer voyez je vais vous dire moi
je veux bien tout entendre mais pas
n'importe quoi on a évoqué tout à
l'heure au QG de situations
de mort forcément tragique
une femme de 44 ans qui est morte à
Nanterre qui était magistrate elle est
tombée foudroyée à l'audience la
communauté sa famille d'abord la
communauté judiciaire est sous le choc
on peut pas instrumentaliser ça
il y aura un certain nombre de réponses
qui sont apportés sans doute pas toutes
c'est toujours quelque chose qui
peut-être plus réfectorielle j'en sais
rien mais on peut pas utiliser ça
et puis il y a eu le suicide d'une jeune
femme quatre mois plus tard on a utilisé
suicide j'ai demandé une inspection pour
en savoir davantage il y a un certain
nombre de choses que j'estimais de ne
pas devoir rendre public
et ça aussi je pense qu'on peut pas
l'instrumentaliser
voilà maintenant je vais vous dire
quelque chose on peut toujours faire
mieux
mais
avant de critiquer qu'on regarde ce que
soi-même on a pu faire je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure sous la gauche de 2012 à 2017
c'est 14,9 % d'augmentation du budget
sous madame toburin c'était des budgets
en augmentation d'un pour cent
non mais je dis pas qu'elle aurait bien
pas voulu
j'imagine qu'elle aurait voulu même
doubler ça n'aurait fait que 2% mais
enfin nous on en est à plus 8 madame
Hunter Mayer vous savez que je vous aime
beaucoup d'accord mais je parle de
chiffres là je non mais moi moi je veux
bien je veux bien être critiqué je veux
bien être critiqué sur mon budget mais
je constate quand même que je constate
quand même je constate quand même que
d'un point de vue syndical il y avait
peu de critiques quand on était dans des
budgets à l'époque à 1% maintenant je
vais terminer mon propos c'était entre
2012 et 2017
14,9%, c'est 44% depuis que le Président
de la République est président de la
République pardon de vous le dire voilà
alors je termine mon propos je comprends
que tout cela puisse vous je comprends
tout cela puisse je comprends tout cela
puisse je comprends que tout cela puisse
vous déranger je vais je vais finir vous
avez évoqué l'inflation
monsieur le député en disant mais au
fond 8% l'inflation etc alors je
voudrais vous dire d'abord que le taux
d'inflation moyen national il concerne
les consommateurs individuels il
s'appliquent pas strictement à un
ministère le plus grand coup lié à
l'inflexion pour la justice en 2023
c'est le financement de la
revalorisation du point d'indice des
agents publics de 3,5% ce qui représente
128 millions d'euros pour 2023 soit 70%
soit mais écoutez ma réponse
soit 70% de l'inflation comptabilisée
dans le budget justice
2023 bon enfin
je voudrais vous dire à vous aussi une
chose toute simple
j'aime le Parlement quand le débat y est
serein oui oui bien sûr je pense que
c'est un lieu de co-construction et je
pense avoir démontré très nombreuses
reprises mais je voudrais rappeler tout
simplement après on peut toujours voilà
que plus ce n'est pas égal à moins et
que moi je ne rougis pas de comparer les
budgets que nous avons obtenus avec ceux
qui ont été obtenus par d'autres dans
d'autres temps bon tout en disant que
bien sûr tout n'est pas terminé qu'il
reste des choses à faire d'ailleurs
député du rassemblement national qui
m'ont demandé quand je démissionnerai
mais si j'avais le sentiment d'avoir
tout fait vous voyez je partirai mais
j'ai le sentiment que tout n'a pas été
accompli donc ils vont souffrir un peu
que voilà bien allez monsieur Balanant
le ministre a beaucoup de réponses à
vous apporter et j'imagine que vous avez
beaucoup de questions pour lui plus vous
le perturberez moins vous aurez des
questions ensuite pour lui poser parce
que le temps n'est pas illimité et on a
des amendements examinés donc si vous
pouvez laisser répondre si vous voulez
et puis après on en fera que les
amendements merci merci Monsieur Merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le Député
Coulomme j'ai encore quelque chose à
vous dire
si le député le les références au cpège
là que vous faites pour beaucoup d'entre
vous elle ne valent rien parce que
maintenant il y a deux ans de retard
pardon de dire que ça s'arrête à 2020 je
vous indique qu'on parle du budget 2023
et qu'on est en 2022 ce qui n'échappe à
personne je vais vous dire autre chose
j'ai j'ai déjà dit de nombreuses
reprises qu'on ne peut pas comparer avec
l'Allemagne à plus d'un titre et vous
faites de grands yeux je vais vous dire
pourquoi d'abord parce que nous avons
des juges consulaires qui ne sont pas
des magistrats professionnels
deuxièmement parce que nous avons des
conseillers prudemaux qui ne sont pas
des magistrats professionnels
troisièmement parce que le droit
anglo-saxon et plus pardon pour la
formule gourmande en magistrats que
notre droit à nous c'est aussi écrit ça
dans le rapport et c'est ce que dit
d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes mais si
vous me balancez un rapport
d'abord je pense qu'il faut avoir
l'intellectuel l'intellectuel de
rappeler qu'il concerne des années qui
ne sont qui ne sont même pas les miennes
je le dis et puis deuxièmement de dire
ce que la cour compte a dit de ce
rapport et puis troisièmement de
constater un certain nombre de données
chiffrées que je m'échine à vous à vous
à vous exposer voilà alors Monsieur
Balanant monsieur Balanant
monsieur baladant je suis tellement au
moins tellement fier que l'on est
ensemble ensemble et ça concerne aussi
madame Cécile
bien sûr et et et tous les députés de
cette majorité porter ce texte sur les
mineurs le code de justice pénale des
mineurs j'entendais là aussi puisqu'on a
fait référence à la campagne
présidentielle
les gens du rassemblement national qui
disaient mais il faut réformer la
justice pénale des mineurs mais oui
c'était fait et vous n'étiez pas à
l'Assemblée il faut dire que vous la
fréquentiez peu à l'époque Madame Le Pen
a surtout brillé pour son absence bon
enfin bref bah alors les autres le
savaient pas mais peu importe oui mais
je je je
voudrais dire
je voudrais dire je voudrais dire que
nous
ce président
s'il vous plaît je termine là je
voudrais dire
je voudrais dire que nous avons
maintenant un retour d'expérience qui
est de plus d'un an que ça fonctionne et
que ça marche et que je vais pour rappel
pour dire qu'on a fait quand même
quelques trucs vous voyez
les mineurs ils étaient une fois sur
deux jugés quand ils étaient majeurs
grâce à ce texte ils sont aujourd'hui
jugés dans un délai maximal de huit mois
bon et on peut estimer tous ensemble
enfin je l'espère que c'est extrêmement
important quand on s'attaque à la
délinquance des mineurs de leur apporter
une réponse pénale extrêmement rapide
bon donc monsieur Balanant moi je prends
tous ces enthousiasmes avec beaucoup de
bonheur et puis s'agissant du
harcèlement scolaire qui était
une thématique sur lesquelles vous êtes
totalement investi je suis mille fois
d'accord avec vous
pour qu'il y ait un renforcement entre
les liens renforcement des liens entre
éducation nationale et justice je dois
dire que nous nous arrivons d'ailleurs
on reproche beaucoup de choses à la
justice c'est on reproche pas au médecin
la maladie mais reproche au garde des
sceaux la délinquance et quand nous nous
sommes saisis au fond il est déjà bien
tard parce que plein de choses n'ont pas
marché l'éducation n'a pas marché
des gamins des enfin il y a mille
raisons qui expliquent et mille raisons
sociologiques que certains appellent la
culture de l'excuse mais ça existe ça
moi quand je suis confronté à un
féminicite qui n'a donné lieu
préalablement à aucune alerte
expliquez-moi comment on peut intervenir
si ce n'est bien sûr dire à quel point
la prévention c'est important dire que
ces histoires de féminicite c'est
l'histoire de tout le monde et même
l'histoire des voisins ça oui bien sûr
qu'on peut le faire mais pour le reste
il faut relativiser les choses et
s'exprimer avec une nuance qui n'est
plus qui n'est plus la norme et qui
n'est plus la règle alors Monsieur
bouquin
bon réduction des délais je vais quand
même vous dire quelque chose que vous
que vous ignorez
bien sûr que la justice est beaucoup
trop longue
vous savez dans les états généraux la
plateforme citoyenne fait apparaître
deux choses on ne connaît pas
suffisamment la justice c'est premier
item deuxième item la justice trop
longue j'ai toujours dit moi je l'ai dit
dans les dans les dès que j'ai prononcé
mon discours à l'arrivée sur le perron
de la Chancellerie j'ai dit c'est trop
long bon
on a embauché des contractuels quand je
l'ai fait on m'a regardé au mieux avec
circonspection au pire c'était un déluge
de critique et pourquoi vous n'embauchez
pas des magistrats visible parce qu'on
n'a pas le temps de les former c'est
contractuel
18 mois plus tard on m'a demandé de les
pérenniser ce qu'est la démonstration de
ce qu'on sait pas tromper mais c'était
audacieux de les mettre en place ils ont
diminué avec les magistrats
naturellement qu'ils sont censés aider
qu'ils aient au quotidien on a diminué
les stocks en matière civile
de près de 30 % chiffre national et en
matière pénale on a diminué aussi ça
veut dire que la justice va plus vite
mais elle doit aller encore plus vite
elle doit être encore plus protectrice
d'où les 1500 magistrats qui seront
embauchés les 1500 greffiers les
contractuels et un certain nombre de
moyens matériels pour permettre
justement qu'on ait une justice plus
rapide et dans les réformes des états
généraux de la justice
et dernière consultations sont terminées
il y a quelques jours on va présenter et
vous serez évidemment associé à ça à la
fois du règlementaire et du législatif
dans le réglementaire il y a tout un tas
de dispositions civiles qui font l'objet
de consensus et qui vont permettre
d'alléger la procédure civile
et donc d'aller plus vite je pense à
l'équipe autour du magistrat je pense
à d'autres mesures qui vont permettre
d'aller davantage vers de la médiation
sans oublier je le dis pour une avocate
qui m'a interpellé à qui je vais
répondre dans un instant sans oublier
qu'il faut inciter aussi les avocats à
aller vers la médiation c'est à dire les
pays comme s'ils allaient au procès bon
donc tout ça voyez-vous va se faire et
vous serez pleinement associé à ça moi
j'ai souhaité je vous le dis
instaurer une nouvelle gouvernance
on a eu le rapport sauvé on a eu les
annexes j'ai transmis à tout le monde
j'ai reçu tout le monde tout le monde
tout le monde sans exception sauf ceux
qui n'ont pas souhaité franchir ma porte
mais ça c'est leur responsabilité bon
parce que ces états généraux c'est notre
objectif commun
et on a retenu
tout ce qui était consensuel parce que
je me suis dit que si nous devions faire
une présentation au Parlement en ferant
une présentation sur de législatif mais
même sur le réglementaire il fallait que
l'on ressorte ce sur quoi nous étions
tous d'accord mais c'est pas de l'eau
tiède qui ressort de ces états généraux
parce que je pense que tout le monde a
compris c'était une chance historique de
moderniser notre justice et de la rendre
plus efficace plus protectrice plus
rapide bon donc bien sûr que nous aurons
ces discussions vous inquiétez pas je
vais pas faire ça dans mon coin
masquer ce sera un visage découvert et
on partage avec vous bien sûr le moment
venu et le moment arrive là je pense que
on a une feuille de route qui nous
permet de dire que
mi-novembre on devrait présenter les
choses et vous aurez le loisir la
possibilité bien sûr de de regarder de
trouver ça bien de critiquer enfin voilà
le travail qui est le vôtre et que et
que je ne je n'entends pas négliger bien
sûr voilà
alors ensuite ensuite madame Cécile
Hunter Mayer
d'abord vous me dites que vous serez
raisonnable était
utile de le préciser vous l'êtes
toujours madame la députée
allez
vous allez comparer emploi MJ emploi MJ
emplois émis ministère d'intérieur 8500
nous 10000 bon sur le quinquennat vous
me dites la détention provisoire ne
diminue pas c'est vrai ce qui est encore
une réponse à ceux qui affirment sans
jamais s'y est que la justice n'est pas
laxiste
mais franchement
non mais moi je lui réponds parce que
je réponds à ces électeurs aussi non
mais ok vous voyez la justice elle axis
qu'est-ce que vous faites rien pensez
que nous taper dessus mais ok tout ça
c'est bien mais il y a quelques limites
quand même vous voyez la justice n'est
pas laxiste les prisons sont pleines
archi pleines la détention provisoire ne
faiblit pas ne Mollie pas et on peut pas
à la fois reprocher au ministère d'être
laxiste et lui reprocher la
surpopulation carte serral vous voyez
j'entends bien j'ai pris note de la
mission d'évaluation
CGPM bien sûr que vous réalisez avec
notre ami Jean nombre de mineurs détenus
en baisse depuis le code de justice
pénale des mineurs
alors entendez bien que on peut penser
que c'est parce que ça marche
enfin pardon ouais 12 % moins
et
à ceux qui ne veulent pas entendre un
certain nombre de réalité
il semble que la délinquance des mineurs
est baissée alors maintenant il faut
faire expertiser ça de près ne pas se
réjouir trop vite
mais voilà les chiffres que nous avons
et sur lesquels il faut que l'on
s'arrête un petit un petit instant voilà
sans être toujours dans la dans la la
posture je pense que la justice mérite
autre chose que des postures et que des
affirmations idéologiques bon sur la PGJ
et les effectifs de PJJ c'est 92
créations d'emplois en PLF 2023 qui
viennent s'inscrire dans la continuité
des 338 créations d'emplois dédiés sur
la période 2018-2022 voilà ce que je
peux dire il nous accentuerons les
efforts sur le quinquennat
sur les logiciels alors la Cour de
cassation et le Conseil d'État des
logiciels dont je vous confirme qu'il
marche très bien directeur de cabinet
témoin privilégié mais il semblerait
qu'on est là un problème d'adaptation et
de gestion des flux bon alors on va
renforcer le réseau et nous avons eu
l'idée je pense qu'elle est bien
accueillie dans les juridictions
d'envoyer un spécialiste de
l'informatique pour régler les problèmes
qui se posent sur place
dans chaque jeu dans chaque dans chaque
juridique bon ensuite Monsieur Didier Le
Maire alors m'a demandé si j'étais en
mesure de lui dire le nombre de
magistrats qui seraient affecté à chaque
juridiction ma réponse est non c'est
parce que c'est la direction des
services judiciaires qui fait ça dans le
cadre de ce que l'on appelle le dialogue
de gestion mais je voudrais vous dire
que nous avons
j'accélère mais je voudrais vous dire
que nous avons créé pour Cayenne et pour
Mayotte une brigade de soutien il y a un
problème d'attractivité dans ces
juridictions et nous avons créé ça
n'existait pas une brigade qui va nous
permettre de demander à des magistrats
qui sont en poste en métropole d'aller
travailler six mois à Cayenne ou six
mois à Mayotte d'avoir la certitude de
retrouver leur poste
pour justement régler ces questions et
nous avions besoin évidemment de Laval
du Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
et nous l'avons obtenu bon alors
pense vous avoir à peu près répondu
monsieur monsieur monsieur jordanoff sur
la question des stocks j'ai déjà donné
les chiffres c'était une de vos
préoccupations tout à fait légitime sur
ces pêches j'ai déjà répondu
madame Émeline
cabinet je voudrais vous rappeler que il
y avait je sais pas si vous en souvenez
un rapport Perben oui il y avait
beaucoup d'avocats dans ce rapport
urbaine constaté un certain nombre de
choses nous avons dépassé ce que pervers
préconisé en matière de de hausse de
l'agit pour mémoire 2020 on est à 430
millions d'euros 2023 641 ça fait une
augmentation de plus de 50%
voilà
et puis monsieur Jean-Philippe Aquaviva
on peut pas recruter d'un soin on peut
pas recruter d'un seul coup 1500
magistrats pour une raison toute simple
c'est qu'il faut les former et leur
donner bien sûr une formation de qualité
et à hauteur de leur futur
responsabilités il faut donc si on veut
être sérieux
cadencer les recrutements et les
concours avec
des locaux et des
enseignants voilà la réponse que que je
peux fournir je pense que elle est un
peu sommaire mais elle est assez
compréhensible
voilà
merci alors j'ai encore 9 questions
monsieur Rémi réberotte pour deux
minutes cette fois-ci
chers collègue quelques mots simplement
et une question pour accélérer la
justice pour désengorger des
juridictions éviter la
correctionnalisation de crimes grave ont
été créés les cours criminels
départementales
nous sortons nous sommes en train de
sortir de l'expérimentation et a été
commencé donc leur généralisation qui se
poursuivra donc en 2023 notre siège de
cour d'appel de Dijon puisque nous
sommes Bourguignons avec Didier Paris
n'a pas encore de ses cours criminel
départemental et les magistrats que nous
avons rencontré récemment
sont impatients de voir se réaliser
l'installation de telles institutions
aussi bien en Haute-Marne en Côte-d'Or
quand Saône-et-Loire est-ce que vous
pourriez nous faire un premier bilan du
fonctionnement de ces nouvelles
institutions et de leurs déploiement et
qu'en est-il justement de cette
généralisation sur l'ensemble du
territoire merci Madame Pascal borde
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les avocats acteurs clés de
notre démocratie sont les vecteurs
naturels de l'accès au droit ils sont à
ce titre pleinement engagés dans la
défense de l'ensemble des justiciers
quel que soit leur revenu cette défense
s'organise notamment grâce à l'aide
juridictionnelle qui permet à toute
personne dépourvu de ressources
suffisantes d'accéder à un juge et de
bénéficier d'une défense de qualité
cependant tous les rapports
parlementaires ou ceux issus d'une
mission Haddock dont le la mission
perven ou celui du Comité sur les états
généraux de la Justice ont conclu que le
budget de l'aide juridictionnelle était
insuffisant pour couvrir l'ensemble des
besoins des justiciables même si des
évolutions ont été réalisées ces
derniers mois avoir ces dernières années
ce budget ne permet pas non plus
d'assurer une rémunération acceptable
des avocats qui interviennent au titre
de l'aide juridictionnelle toute plus
peut-on parler de rétribution mais pas
de juste rémunération depuis des années
les avocats travaillent en grande
majorité à lorsqu'ils sont rétribués au
titre de la juridictionnelle puisque
l'indemnisation versée par l'État en fin
de procédure ne couvre pas l'ensemble
des frais engagés par les cabinets
concernés certes il y a eu ces dernières
années une légère augmentation du nombre
du V pour certaines procédures ainsi
qu'une augmentation du montant de l'UV
qui est à ce jour de 36 euros alors que
le rapport perbent préconisé il y a
quelques mois 40 euros mais la
rétribution elle est allouée aux avocats
n'est toujours pas acceptable elle est
d'autant moins période d'inflation
galopante inflation que les cabinets
d'avocats ne peuvent pas supporter sur
leur deniers propres pas plus qu'ils ne
peuvent continuer à être la variable
d'ajustement d'un système à bout de
souffle la revalorisation de la J est
donc indispensable et urgente or les
crédits budgétaires consacrés à l'agit
dans le PLF pour 2023 ressorte à 641
millions d'euros soit une hausse de
4,2%. il ne me paraissent pas permettre
de tendre vers cet objectif d'où ma
question entendez-vous procéder
rapidement à une revalisation de la j
revalorisation pardon de la de façon à
prendre en compte le rattrapage de
l'inflation merci Monsieur Hugo
banalisis
le micro
vous avez glissé un élément au détour de
votre propos luminaire sur la question
du moratoire qui prend fin sur
cellulement individuel au 31 décembre
2022 à ma connaissance je ne vois pas de
texte concernant la justice à l'agenda
parlementaire d'ici le 31 décembre 2022
comment allez-vous faire pour faire en
sorte de prolonger le moratoire comme
vous l'avez indiqué une dernière fois
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2027 si je
comprends bien bon je reviendrai pas sur
le fait que quand on nous a vendu le
décalage du moratoire au 31 décembre
2022 on nous expliquant qu'en
construisant des places de prison et en
diminuant les courtes peines tout ça
allait rentrer dans les clous bon ça n'a
pas fonctionné et quitte à parler des
Pays-Bas comme vous l'avez cité tout à
l'heure effectivement on peut remarquer
que au Pays-Bas ils ont entamé une
politique de déflation pénale qui a
conduit à la diminution de
l'incarcération et donc à la fermeture
de prison et de place de place de prison
et donc de
je pense qu'effectivement on pourrait
s'inspirer habilement d'un certain
nombre d'éléments qui nous proviennent
des Pays-Bas et ce n'est sans doute pas
le seul autre questionnement au delà de
le moratoire on a parlé du de la justice
pénale des mineurs mais je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur la justice
civile des mineurs et nous avons des
graves difficultés dans le département
du Nord mais pas que pour l'exécution
des décisions prises par les magistrats
est-ce qu'il est prévu que vous puissiez
avoir une discussion ferme comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure non pas avec
les prestataires du bar cette fois-ci
mais avec les conseils départementaux et
les exécutifs parce que ça ne peut pas
durer que ces décisions ne puissent pas
être exécutées dans l'intérêt supérieur
des enfants et pour les protéger
merci Madame Émilie Chandler
monsieur le ministre merci de répondre à
nos questions dans le cadre de ces
missions ma mission ma question porte
sur les violences intrafamiliales le
Grenelle sur les violences faites aux
femmes en 2019 a permis la mise en place
de 10 mesures phares en faveur des
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
parmi celles-ci celle du contrôle
judiciaire avec placement probatoire a
connu une extension géographique à
l'ensemble du territoire au 1er avril de
cette année ce placement est une
alternative à la détention provisoire en
prenant en charge les visions immédiates
d'un auteur de violence conjugales et sa
prise en charge dans un hébergement
adapté adapté
dans les documents budgétaires qui nous
ont été fournis il est indiqué que les
crédits dédiés au service pénitentiaire
d'insception
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre 4 points que je
souhaitais vous soumettre le premier et
vous l'avez très très largement évoqué à
raison il me semble concerne
l'attractivité
de du personnel de l'administration
pénitentiaire je pense qu'il n'est pas
utile que vous reveniez dessus encore
une fois mais également je souhaitais et
bien assurer ces femmes et ces hommes
qui exercent sans doute un métier parmi
les plus éprouvants de tout mon soutien
et on doit pouvoir en effet leur assurer
bien de rejoindre leur famille à l'issue
de leur service mon second point
concerne la prévention de la récidive
pour prévenir la récidive nous devons
rendre les détenus meilleurs à la sortie
qu'il n'était alors entrées en évitant
par exemple la radicalisation par
contact avec les détenus radicalisés
prosélytes mais aussi par un
accompagnement vers la sortie ou encore
j'en persuadé en affectant vous l'avez
également évoqué 130 millions d'euros à
la rénovation et à la modernisation du
parc pénitentiaire existant le budget
qui nous est proposé prend en compte la
mise en place de nombre de mesures que
nous avons adoptées enfin du précédent
mandat avec notamment la création du
contrôle d'emploi pénitentiaire monsieur
le ministre je sais que vous y êtes très
attaché pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur l'avancement de vos travaux sur la
mise en place de ce contrat un troisième
point concerne la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse nous faisons là aussi
face une crise de vocation pour tous ces
métiers je suis très régulièrement
alerté par des éducateurs qui craquent
qui sont tentés de baisser les bras il
ne s'agit pas de jeunes arrivants mais
des personnes avec 15 ans 20 ans de
métier ils font face à une très forte
évolution des violences il font face à
des cas qui nécessiteraient parfois une
prise en charge psychiatrique ou
d'autres mesures plus fermes comment
pourrions-nous monsieur linis lutter
contre ces comportements de plus en plus
violents pour que le métier du capteur
revienne à sa première acception
l'éducation je vous remercie merci
Monsieur romain Baubry
merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur je suis David puisque toute
là vous avez vous avez parlé de la
réinsertion des détenus et notamment des
activités qui étaient proposées de nous
expliquer en quoi faire de la voie à
long militaire année participe à
réinsérer les détenus à lutter contre la
récidive concernant monsieur le garde
des sceaux alors mes questions vont
porter sur l'administration
pénitentiaire en premier lieu sur le
personnel vos mesures catégorielles pour
valoriser les salaires sont faibles et
ne vont pas permettre à l'administration
pénitentiaire de recruter ou alors il
faut espérer que comme sous l'ancien
quinquennat vous ne construisiez aucune
place de prison supplémentaire
31% du budget consacré au revalorisation
salariale sont à destination des
directeurs mais ce n'est pas un
directeur qui se trouve derrière la
porte d'une cellule dont vous auriez dû
consacrer davantage vous auriez dû
consacrer davantage pour celles et ceux
qui sont en première ligne celles et
ceux sans qui aucune porte ne s'ouvre
alors comment attirer des candidats si
vous n'offrez même pas un salaire
descend déjà que vous n'êtes vous êtes
incapable de leur sortir un rythme de
travail digne le manque de personnel de
surveillance c'est la cause notamment
d'assassinat en détention et il était
espéré qu'il vous restera pas comme vous
l'avez fait la dernière fois à jeter de
nouveau en pâture des surveillants
pénitentiaires comme l'affaire de la
centrale d'Arles avec le
des tenues avant Colonna alors Monsieur
le monsieur le garde des sceaux comment
comptez-vous attirer des candidats au
sein de l'administration pénitentiaire
et petite remarque concernant la
sécurité de ces établissements là aussi
les moyens mis en oeuvre dans ce budget
n'y sont pas pour compenser la carence
de la surveillance humaine rendue
possible par ce manque d'ambition pour
l'administration et là je pense
notamment aux projections de drogue
d'armes de téléphone de livraison par
drone il va falloir mettre davantage de
budget pour assurer la sécurité
périphérique et la sécurité interne des
établissements je vous remercie
je vous donne la parole
merci je reviens en deuxième partie
je vais recommencer depuis le départ
c'est mieux monsieur le ministre donc ma
question porte sur les violences
centrales familiales le Grenelle sur les
violences faites aux femmes en 2019 a
permis la mise en place de 10 mesures
phares en faveur des victimes de
violence conjugales parmi celles-ci
celle du contrôle judiciaire avec
placement probatoire a connu une
extension géographique à l'ensemble du
territoire depuis le 1er avril de cette
année ce placement est une alternative à
la détention provisoire en prenant en
charge les viction immédiate d'un auteur
de violence conjugales et sa prise en
charge dans un hébergement adapté dans
les documents budgétaires qui nous ont
été fournis il est indiqué que les
crédits dédiés au service pénitentiaire
d'insertion et de probation les spips
étaient augmentés de 34% soit 14
millions d'euros
cette augmentation inclut notamment le
financement du déploiement cjpp au
regard de l'extension géographique de
l'expérimentation quelle part de ses 40
millions et destiné justement au cjpp
merci Monsieur Didier Paris
merci monsieur le Président
vous avez évoqué beaucoup de sujets
monsieur
monsieur homini je vais pas reprendre de
discussions techniques manifestement on
est dans une période charnière de
l'histoire de la justice et vous avez
beaucoup peu vrai depuis deux ans trois
ans pour un faire évoluer
en vous appuyant par ailleurs sur les
états généraux de la justice en fait
vous avez réussi je trouve le tour de
force de créer les conditions d'une
justice qui s'adapte qui se modernise
donc sans de plus de lisibilité de plus
d'efficacité de plus de rapidité
maintenant les chiffres sont les
chiffres ils sont exceptionnels vous
l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises et je
crois que nous en sommes tous conscients
en dépit des potions politiques qui
peuvent qui peuvent parfois s'exprimer
la question que je me pose monsieur
ministre et donc je vous pose c'est
au-delà des chiffres est-ce que dans
l'état de réflexion qui est le vôtre et
en prévision d'une loi
prochaine loi d'orientation et de
modernisation ou d'évolution de la
justice est-ce que vous êtes en train de
poser les bases d'une évolution de la
gouvernance de notre système judiciaire
je pense en particulier la manière dont
le budget s'exécute dans les
juridictions le taux de liberté des
juridictions le dialogue de gestion ou
de décision dont nous avons vu à
plusieurs reprises que il était encore
relativement faible je peux aussi faire
référence à la réorganisation des cours
d'appel vous avez évoqué le système
numérique avec la nomination d'un
secrétaire général adjoint c'est une
attente très puissante du corps
judiciaire d'avoir enfin un dispositif
numérique qui correspondent à ces
attentes est-ce que
est-ce à l'instar de cette évolution là
vous prévoyez encore d'autres modes de
fonctionnement qui permettraient de sur
multiplier les efforts budgétaires
exceptionnels qui sont les vôtres
merci Madame Elsa faucillon
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout à l'heure je me fâchais un
peu quand je vous entendais railler ou
accréditer le terme de laxisme comme
s'il existait quand on parlait de
justice ou de prison ici un camp du
laxisme tant ce terme semble cacher trop
souvent l'idée d'une conditionnalité ou
d'une optionalité du respect des droits
humains et donc je crois qu'il faut
combattre à tout prix ce terme il rime
d'ailleurs avec cette espèce de
suffixation terrible qui est le droit de
lomissement ici je le crois il faut à
tout prix et c'est un combat en tant que
parlementaire
œuvré pour le respect des droits humains
et je crois que il ne faut surtout pas
banaliser en tout cas celles et ceux qui
contestent cette défense des droits
humains je mets ça en lien avec le sujet
de mon interpellation sur la question de
des conditions de détention des détenus
d'autres l'ont rappelé mais il y de
multiples condamnations de la Cour
européenne de droits de l'homme des
arrêts de la Cour de cassation une
décision aussi enfin une consécration
par le Conseil constitutionnel de
l'interdiction de soumettre les
personnes détenues à des conditions
d'incarcération contraire à la dignité
humaine nous avons aussi parlé ici de
surpopulation carcérale et d'un pays qui
continue de toujours plus enfermer et je
dirais à contrario de beaucoup de nos
voisins européens alors il y a le plan
15000 palaces qui sera peut-être 13000
qui sera peut-être 11000 je n'en sais
rien comme ce fut le cas dans des temps
passés moi je crois que l'appel a de
nouvelles peines à plus d'enfermement ça
semble faire un certain succès comme
slogan politique mais il faut le répéter
ça ne répète ça ne protège en rien nos
concitoyens et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
la prison ne protège pas bien la société
pour mieux diriger peut-être les budgets
aujourd'hui plutôt vers l'insertion vers
les peines altern mais aussi vers les
conditions de travail des agents
pénitentiaires je crois qui est venu le
temps de la régulation carcérale et du
non-inflation carcérale voilà si votre
avis
merci monsieur le Président à l'instar
des propos quand il tenus par mon
collègue Didier Paris je voudrais à mon
tour monsieur le ministre vous dire tout
le courage qui a été le vôtre de porter
cette réforme sur le code de justice
pénale des mineurs
souvenons-nous l'ordonnance de 1945 vécu
comme un totem vous l'avez rappelé à de
nombreuses fois modifier à 40
entreprises et véritablement personne
pour engager cette réforme structurelle
et si nécessaire et s'y attendu du code
de justice pénale des mineurs
et il faut bien le dire cette réforme
est avant tout une réforme aussi de
procédure avec des objectifs importants
souvenons-nous 18 mois de jugement pour
pour un mineur Vous l'avez rappelé aussi
également jugé dans bien dans la
majorité des cas alors qu'ils étaient
majeurs et avec une ambition celle de
réduire ce délai à huit mois et une des
critiques principales qui avait été
celle de ce de cette réforme envisagée
était celle des moyens financiers et
matériels mis à la disposition de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse en
rappelant que si l'on pouvait juger plus
rapidement sur la culpabilité que si on
pouvait juger plus rapidement sur la
sanction et bien il fallait mettre à un
moment donné sur les mesures éducatives
des moyens et c'est chose faite et je
voudrais ici le souligner c'est des
chiffres vous les avez rappelé 1,1
milliard d'euros de crédit de paiement
pour la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse
10,4% d'augmentation du budget en 2022
et c'est des emplois 92 créations
en 2023 +
13,6%. et tout cela s'accompagne dans un
cheminement où l'on voit en 2021 mais
également une tendance qui se confirme
en 2022 d'une baisse du nombre des
affaires pénales concernant les mineurs
et donc ma question est la suivante
est-ce que vous avez peut-être un peu
trop tôt déjà envisagé perçu les raisons
pour lesquelles outre évidemment la mise
en place de ce code de justice
mineur les raisons qui pourraient être
celle d'une baisse de cette de cette
délinquance merci enfin Monsieur
Timothée Houssain merci monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous interpeller
sur l'objectif 2 renforcer l'efficacité
de la réponse pénale le sens et
l'efficacité de la peine lorsqu'on lit
le titre de l'objectif on ne peut qu'il
souscrire pour autant les chiffres qui
nous sont présentés semblent être en
contradiction avec cet objectif le taux
d'alternative aux poursuites avec mesure
de rappel à la loi passerait de 39% en
2021 à 45% en 2025 le taux de Pen
alternative à l'emprisonnement de 76% en
2021 ce qui est conséquent et vous
ciblez 78% en 2022 79 en 2023 80 en 2024
80 en 2025 comme si vider les prisons
était un objectif en soi on nous dit
explicitement que l'objectif est de
réduire le nombre de peine inférieures à
6 mois au profit d'une ridicule peine de
détention à domicile sous surveillance
électronique et la loi interdit de
prononcer des peines d'emprisonnement de
moins d'un mois on marche à l'envers
alors qu'il faudrait sanctionner
réellement dès les premières
condamnations par des très courtes
peines on acte le fait que la non
incarcération pour courte peine n'est
pas un palliatif au manque de place de
prison mais un objectif pour 2023 les
autorisations d'engagement pour
l'administration pénitentiaire sont en
baisse de 17%, c'est une politique et un
budget de renoncement avec un
effondrement des autorisations
d'engagement à partir de 2025 dans le
détail on observe deux grandes
problématiques d'une part des dépenses
de personnel qui stagne un moyen terme
avec une hausse prévue de 13% en 3 ans
ce qui au vu de l'inflation
semble ne pas correspondre à une
augmentation réelle des effectifs et des
capacités d'incarcération et d'autre
part des dépenses d'investissement qui
si elles atteignent un milliard en 2022
s'effondre de 80% à l'horizon 2025 au vu
du manque de place et de l'état des
prisons c'est un suffisant on nous parle
de 15000 ouverture de places pour 2027
mais au vu du budget il semble qu'après
2027 il n'est plus grand chose de prévu
c'est constat pose question dans le même
temps des places vont-elles disparaître
et quel objectif de nombre de places
vous fixez-vous à long terme sachant que
86000 personnes exécutent une peine
privative de liberté et que nous n'avons
que 60000 places de prison c'est à vous
monsieur le ministre pour la réponse à
cette série de questions avant que nous
l'avions la séance
d'abord nos amis Bourguignons puisque
ils ont cru de voir
nous rappeler qu'ils étaient
bourguignons
mais c'est lui qui l'a dit mais il vous
a visé monsieur le député
très bien bon la loi de décembre du 22
décembre 2021 pour la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire prévoit la
généralisation des cours criminels
départementales à compter du 1er janvier
2023 bon sur la cycle d'abord je me
félicite que vous ayez été en contact
avec
les magistrats de votre ressort qui sont
si j'ai bien entendu impatient
impatient de voir se mettre en place la
cour criminelle départementale bon je
peux pas vous donner davantage de
précision sur la situation
bourguignonne on se passe un petit coup
de fil je vous donne les renseignements
dès que je les ai mais voilà
généralisation on a la date on a vécu un
petit retard me semble-t-il en
expérimentation je pense que voilà le
texte en vigueur quand il est du 1er
janvier les avantages des inconvénients
du texte
et de la mise en place de cette
juridiction c'est que d'abord ça va plus
vite en termes d'audiencement que ça
règle la question lancinant de la
correctionnalisation parce que les
victimes de viol
n'acceptaient plus plus du tout l'idée
que leur dossier soit jugé en
correctionnel il y a une évolution
puisque à un moment vous savez la
correctionnalisation il fallait demander
l'avis à la victime naturellement il y
avait des acceptations je pense que
c'est de plus en plus mal vécu et donc
l'avantage de la cour départementale
criminel départemental c'est de régler
cette question il y avait un taux
d'appel qui était inférieur au taux
d'appel des cours des des verdicts
rendus par les cours d'assistes
classiques rappelons d'ailleurs que les
cours d'assises dites classiques
subsistent parce que si un appel est
interjeté c'est évidemment devant une
cour d'assise classique traditionnelle
que que l'accusé sera jugée
les magistrats étaient contents dans les
rapports que nous avions
de de de cette juridiction bon voilà
je pense qu'on a fait une oeuvres utile
ne fut-ce qu'avec un audiencement
beaucoup plus court
voilà et je pense même d'ailleurs que
les délais la durée du procès est un peu
plus courte sur les cours d'assises sur
les corps criminels départementales bon
sur l'aide juridictionnelle j'ai été
interpellé je voudrais quand même
rappeler
c'est moi-même qui l'avait fait pour
répondre à une question précédente que
naturellement on a pris en considération
le rapport Perben et qu'on est passé de
430 millions d'euros en 2020 à 641
millions d'euros budget 2023 donc c'est
une augmentation de
50% je pense que ça n'est pas neutre que
ce n'est pas rien et qu'on est allé
au-delà
des prescriptions du rapport Perben qui
était notre boussole à un moment il y
avait un certain nombre d'avocats qui
ont évidemment participé à ce rapport
qui ont dit qu'il y avait dans cette
profession bien sûr et c'est vrai un
certain nombre de vrais difficultés je
pense que nous avons fait des efforts
budgétaires substantiels j'avais promis
la première année que nous le ferions en
deux marches j'ai tenu mes engagements
nous en sommes maintenant la troisième
marche n'est pas neutre elle n'est pas
anecdotique et je pense que des efforts
ont été consentis monsieur bernalicis de
choses on va suivre les décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel et je vous
rappelle que lors du dernier report
c'était je vous rappelle je vous indique
parce que je ne le savais pas moi mais
c'était il y a 8 ans et le gouvernement
d'alors avait inséré ce moratoire dans
un texte budgétaire en l'occurrence le
PLFR 2014 donc évidemment on aura
l'occasion de débattre ensemble de cet
amendement je dis par ailleurs sur ce
que vous dites sur
je dis ces gens après demain
mais vous me posez la question je vous
réponds
vous avez compris ce que je veux dire
puisque je procède par voie de très bien
bon par ailleurs sur ce que vous dites
sur les décisions civiles qui concernent
les mineurs je pense que je pense qu'il
y a un vrai sujet
et je pense que il faut qu'on y
travaille ça c'est un sujet névralgique
pour moi je vous ai entendu madame la
député dire faut que la PJ revienne
peut-être je sais pas c'est pas ici
qu'on va dans les rapports non mais je
suis d'accord oui je sais c'est un vrai
sujet il faut qu'on y travaille
madame la députée Blandine brocante bon
oui on sait le métier d'éducateur c'est
pas un métier facile du tout
mais qui est bien difficile comme
l'ensemble des métiers de la filière
sociale en réalité
bon on n'est pas resté sans réponse il y
a une formation spécifique à l'École
Nationale la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse qui fait un vrai boulot pour la
formation initiale la formation continue
de tous les éducateurs de France
un accompagnement professionnel et un
travail d'équipe qui est rendu possible
par des recrutements tutorat pour la
prise de poste et change de pratique
intervisions supervision intervention de
psychologues
et tout ça évidemment c'est un travail
en pluridisciplinarité au soutien des
équipes
338 postes ont été créés à la PJJ sur le
précédent quinquennat et on prévoit donc
créer 92 supplémentaires en 2023 pour
que le soutien aux équipes
l'accompagnement des professionnels soit
également renforcés puis il y a les
évolutions statutaires et indemnitaires
importantes je pense au passage en
catégorie A au passage en catégorie en
2022 et le bénéfice du complément
indiciaire acté en début d'année 2022
aux acteurs du travail social c'est plus
de 1000 euros par an voilà une réponse
que je voudrais vous apporter monsieur
romain bobry je n'ai jamais humilié des
gardiens de la maison d'arrêt d'art si
vous connaissiez vos dossiers vous
seriez que ce dossier là a été géré par
la première ministre à la suite d'un
décret de départ
voilà première remarque que je voudrais
vous faire mais
allez-y ne vous gênez pas il n'en
restera du moins espérer vous toujours
quelque chose je n'ai absolument rien à
voir avec les décisions qui ont été
prises
rien bon pour le reste je vais pas faire
la liste des revalorisations statutaires
indemnitaires à laquelle nous avons non
seulement songé dans un premier temps
puis mise en place dans un deuxième
temps et je pense que là aussi
historiquement
les
agents pénitentiaires n'ont jamais été
revalorisés comme ils l'ont été
je pense aussi à la fusion des grades je
pense que un certain nombre d'autres
mesures
regardez-les dans le détail je voudrais
vous dire c'est quand même assez
paradoxal de souvenirs vous voyez
que vous revendiquez davantage et vous
avez raison c'est bien légitime de se
préoccuper des personnels pénitentiaires
troisième force de sécurité dans notre
pays mais je voudrais vous dire que
l'année dernière vous n'étiez pas au
rendez-vous du vote de budget qui a
permis de mettre en place ce que nous
avons mis en place vous voyez il y a
ceux qui disent il y a ceux qui font
madame la députée Chandler en espérant
que vous allez mieux on a craint
c'est l'émotion
je comprends
bon
circulaire du 23 septembre 2020 en
application de la loi du 30 juillet 2020
contre judiciaire dont vous avez parlé
très renforcé qui constitue une
alternative à la détention provisoire
alors les modalités de prise en charge
sont harmonisées à l'aide d'un
référentiel et d'une convention très
particulière
le cjpp dispose de 165 places pour une
dotation de
2,6 millions d'euros
l'expérimentation c'est d'abord
commencer fin 2020 sur deux sites vous
le savez Nîmes et Colmar et j'ai décidé
une extension sur huit sites
complémentaires sont Bordeaux tour
Amiens
Cayenne Draguignan Saint-Étienne Paris
et Rennes à compter du 1er avril 2022 et
un accompagnement des services est
assuré par la date et la DSCG avec des
déplacements sur site et au 31 juillet
22 97 personnes placées sous-maine
justice ont été prises en charge Jean
bafouille pardon sous cgpp depuis le
début de l'expérimentation et 24
personnes ont fait l'objet d'un
placement extérieur dans les mêmes
structures dans la continuité ou non ou
non du CGP
monsieur monsieur le député Didier Paris
on réfléchit activement une nouvelle
gouvernance
afin de donner au service public de la
justice toute son efficacité bon d'abord
on a constaté
un fonctionnement en silo au fond au
fond où vous l'avez vu déjà
au niveau local moi je demande par
exemple qui est davantage de
communication entre les élus la
préfecture le service de sécurité
défense de sécurité intérieure les
magistrats du siège du parquet bon
après la ferme Mérignac on constate que
tout le monde ne se parle pas
suffisamment ce niveau local mais au
niveau central c'est la même chose il y
a un fonctionnement en silo qui au fond
freine un peu les choses voilà plutôt
que de les rendre fluide bon
nous avons constaté très objectivement
et les directions le disent parfois des
difficultés de transmission DSJ
Direction des Services judiciaire
général et ces préjudiciable au
fonctionnement du ministère donc on veut
une culture qui souhaite une culture
différente et un renforcement des
structures en charge de l'administration
s'agissent budget RH informatique
également au niveau des juridictions ce
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure et
je me permets de dire le permet de dire
parce que ça aussi ça ça
suscite des craintes il n'est pas
question de supprimer une cour d'appel
je le redis parce que certains crient
aille avant d'avoir reçu un coup que
personne ne veut rendre leur porter
bon donc voilà
madame madame faussillon
vous avez raison faut pas je le dis avec
gravité je j'entends ce que vous avez
dit il faut pas il faut pas galeries
on n'a pas le droit de le faire pourquoi
j'ai dit laxiste parce que c'est un
procès qui m'est adressé très
régulièrement vous le savez
bon
les mots ont un sens un double sens et
parfois un contre sens
on nous vend
au fond qu'il suffirait de cogner pour
régler la délinquance dans ce pays si
tel était le cas je voudrais vous dire
qu'il y a des siècles qu'on saurait
non non
pas de du ministre de l'Intérieur auquel
je fais allusion certainement pas
certainement pas ça c'est vous qui en
fait une interprétation politique mais
si vous voulez que deux secondes on
parle des mots et du choix des mots de
grâce ne partons pas tout de suite dans
des discussions qui sont un peu stériles
en tous les cas à mes yeux
en même temps le respect de la loi et
moi j'essaie voilà
et on est difficilement son juge et là
il ne se regarde pas voir d'être à la
fois
ferme sans être démago et d'être
humaniste sans être laxiste c'est un
chemin difficile
fait d'un certain nombre de nuances vous
savez à propos des
des plus défavorisés notre pays je
voudrais vous dire quand même que il y a
évidemment les juridictionnelle dans le
périmètre qui est le mien bien sûr mais
il y a aussi les points de justice qui
sont des lieux
confidentiels et gratuits ou les plus
défavorisées de nos compatriotes
reçoivent les premiers conseils j'ai
souhaité d'ailleurs que les élèves de
l'École nationale de la magistrature
aille dans ses points justice pour
donner les premiers conseils mais si
vous écoutez pas ma réponse je pense que
c'est pas lui
que l'on peut s'apporter
moi j'ai écouté j'ai écouté mais
attendez j'ai écouté j'ai écouté madame
j'ai écouté madame votre votre question
je la trouvais inspirante vous rappeliez
que en certaines matières et en matière
de liberté en particulier on ne pouvait
pas galvauder les mots j'essaie de vous
dire j'essaie de vous dire aussi ce qui
a été fait pour les plus défavorisés je
pense que ça vous intéresse
ce n'est pas votre apanage que de
s'intérêt au plus s'intéresser au plus
défavorisé je pense qu'on peut partager
ça je pense en particulier à l'aide
juridictionnelle je pense au point
justice je pense à la création de
tribunaux de proximité ou à la
recréation de tribunaux pour permettre
au plus défavorisé d'avoir accès à la
justice voilà ce que je voulais dire
et c'est une réponse quant à la
régulation carcérale
la régulation carcérale elle ne peut pas
se faire avec des des indices que l'on
ne pourrait pas dépasser je rappelle je
rappelle que ce sont les juges qui
prononcent des décisions je n'ai de
cesse de dire que les décisions
prononcées sont de plus en plus lourdes
et le garde des sourds ne peut pas
intervenir mais je crois aussi
voyez-vous que quand on nous vend que
les peines
lourdes sont susceptibles d'éradiquer la
délinquance on se trompe je veux dire
que il y a par exemple aux États-Unis
des peines plancher qu'on a abandonné
vous aviez même des gamins qui en état
de récidive étaient condamnés à 20 ans
parce qu'ils avaient volé une pizza et
on a vu que la délinquance ne baissait
pas comme système dur
comme système très dur vous avez ce
système là regardez ce qu'il donne
faites un peu non seulement du droit
comparé mais de l'application du droit
comparé avant de nous sortir des
théories selon lesquelles quant à l'idée
que les petites peines les petites
peines elles sont souvent
désocialisantes bien sûr criminogène
davantage cette expertise depuis des
temps immémoriaux alors vous vous avez
tout réglé vous avez tout trouvé c'est
la grande idée mais moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose et puis après je
répondrai à Jean demain voyez-vous si je
décidais avec vous d'ailleurs parce que
je pourrais pas le faire c'est du
législatif de doubler le quantum des
peines doubler les peines par exemple
demain le meurtre simple c'est puni de
30 ans imaginons que je dise écoutez on
va le punir de
de 60 encore que ce serait une peine
inventée mais pourquoi pas très bien
vous pensez que ça fait du de que ça
diminue le nombre de de domicile dans
notre pays mais vous trompez
complètement là aussi mais mais vous
trompez complètement vous avez vous avez
une posture vous n'avez pas d'analyse
donc c'est facile à dire et vous flatter
les bases instincts en permanence donc
voilà moi ce qui me conduit à ne pas
être d'accord avec vous non pas par
principe mais parce que les solutions
que vous préconisez sont totalement
fausses elles sont incohérentes et elles
sont même dangereuses gens Jean terrier
mon cher Jean j'attends évidemment dire
les conclusions de votre mission
j'ai quelques espérances je me dis que
c'est peut-être un peu grâce à nous
enfin à ceux qui ont voté le texte que
il y a un peu moins de délinquance que
on y arrive en tous les cas moi je suis
convaincu non mais non je sais mais il
le regrette moi je suis convaincu que
que quand on suit on sent on dit d'un
gamin qui est coupable première étape si
il est-il s'il y a pas de preuve voilà
on discute plus on le suit moment
probatoire et puis on le juge au quantum
et on s'intéresse aux victimes je pense
que ça c'est moins criminogène pardon
c'est pas le mot juste mais tu vas
comprendre ce que je veux dire que de
juger un gamin qui a 16 ans quand il en
a 22 parce que soit il s'est encré dans
la délinquance et la procédure n'a plus
aucun sens soit il en est sorti de la
même façon la procédure n'a plus aucun
sens
donc moi je suis plutôt fier de ce texte
et je pense qu'il marche bien et nous
serons bientôt si il y a un lien on peut
faire un lien entre la baisse de la
délinquance des mineurs et ce code de
justice pénal des mineurs et puis enfin
il me reste à répondre
à Monsieur Timothée Houssin question
tout en nuance toute en sagesse
l'administration benitan pénitentiaire
bénéficiant 2023 de la création nette de
89 emplois
489 emplois dédiés à l'ouverture des
nouveaux établissements 320 pour
renforcer les effectifs existants
répartis entre les services et les
missions suivantes 200 emplois pour les
équipes de sécurité pénitentiaire 30
pour la surveillance électronique 90
emplois pour les autres missions
formation initiale continue
développement du travail pénitentiel
service pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation renseignements pénitentiaire
bien sûr à ne pas oublier et les
différentes autres fonctions support
voilà monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur et ministre et bien c'est
terminé nous reprenons à 21h30 pour
l'examen des amendements de la mission